d'asile alors aujourd'hui niveau volet
fermeté et bien les sénateurs se sont
notamment intéressés au sujet de savoir
comment expulser plus facilement les
étrangers qui représentent une menace
grave à l'ordre public et tout de suite
on va rejoindre Mathias araes qui a
suivi pour nous tous les débats dans
l'hémicycle depuis cet après-midi
bonsoir Mathias bonsoir Tam Mathias
racontez-nous un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé toute cet après-midi en ce début
de soirée et ben écoutez Tam on a bien
avancé dans le texte depuis 14 h30 et le
début de la séance du jour on a repris
on était à peu près à l'article 7 bis on
est actuellement à l'article 12 bis pas
moins de 8 articles ont donc été
examinés depuis 14h30 je vous le disais
certains très scrutés vous les avez
évoqué je pense aux articles 7 9 et 10
notamment qui visait notamment à
faciliter la levée des protections
contre les expulsion ou les mission
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français à l'encontre des éanger en
situation irrégulière et qui
représenterait une menace pour l'ordre
public ce n'est évidemment pas les
seuls les seulses protections qui ont
été levé avec ces articles il y en a eu
bien d'autres mais ces deux articles ont
été le fruit d'un accord qu'on voit se
dessiné peu à
peu vu les avancées de ce texte entre le
gouvernement et la majorité sénatoriale
les sénateurs ont ensuite adopté toute
toute une série d'articles un volet
concernant le relevé d'empreinte
digitale de prise de photos d'un
étranger sans son consentement ainsi que
la création d'un fichier des mineurs
étrangers impliqués dans des infractions
pénal l'une des dernières avancées c'est
également une sur laquelle presque tous
les sénateurs se sont accordés c'est la
possibilité d'interdire le placement en
centre de rétention des mineurs de moins
de 16 ans le le ministre s'est
d'ailleurs s'est d'ailleurs prononcé sur
cette possibilité je vous propose de
l'écouter d'Emmanuel Macron qui vous
propose le fait qu'il n'y ait plus de
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administratif donc moi j'entends les
engagements pour dire c'est c'est
affreux tout le monde l'a toujours dit
la Convention européenne mais c'est 1989
la Convention européenne c'est un peu
dommage que des gouvernements non mais
je je non mais je remarque simplement
que c'est un peu dommage que les
gouvernements lorsquil en responsabilité
ne l'avaient jamais proposé voilà je
vous le disais en introduction au moment
où je vous parle on est en train de
débattre de la possibilité de réaliser
des tests osseux pour déterminer l'âge
des mineurs non accompagnés à la suite
il y aura d'autres articles intéressant
laissez-moi vous en parler on va
notamment parler avec l'article 13 de
l'introduction de nouveaux critères
encadrant les titres de séjour fondés
sur le respect des principes de la
République ou encore l'absence de
menaces grave à l'ordre public ou encore
la résidence habituelle en France Merci
Merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes ces
explications on va vous retrouver bien
sûr tout au long de la soirée pour
suivre cette séance dont vous ne
manquerez rien euh ici sur Public Sénat
et tout de suite on va rejoindre
l'émicycle et c'est la sénatrice
socialiste Marie-Pierre de laagontri qui
s'exprime commission il s'agissait de la
Ligue des droits de l'homme mais non
mais c'est pas parce que vous réitérez
que ce que vous dites est fondé et je
regrette c'est très intéressant parce
que c'est un un symptôme de votre
intolérance de ne pas supporter que
d'autres que vous défendent ses points
de vue mais je pense intéressant je
pense
intéressant je préfère voir moi Monsieur
Bonhomme excusez-moi de vous dire ça je
trouve intéressant qu'un président de
département il y a encore oui qu'un
président de département encore il y a
quelques semaine tiennent les propos qu'
a tenu monsieur grosvallet parce que
tout ça est bien gentil vous remettez en
cause les institutions très bien mais je
pense que c'est intéressant voilà et
vous avez écouté je pense les propos de
de notre collègue qui dit la même chose
et qui dit bah écoutez en gros il faut
que l'État nous dise définitivement avec
des méthodes qui soient pas contestables
comment on peut procéd pour établir la
majorité ou pas des enfants plutôt que
de nous laisser le déterminer avec les
moyens du bord c'est-à-dire pas
grand-chose de de
sérieux merci on va passer au vote de
cet amendement 310 avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas adopté le 310 7 avis
de la
commission avis défavorable monsieur le
président du gouvernement mais au voit
qui vote
pour
contre n pas
adopté je suis saisi
de six amendements en discussion commune
le 144 qui c'est qui le
défend madame Darcos merci monsieur le
président confronté à une ance
progression du nombre de mineurs non
accompagnés les départements demandent à
l'État de prendre en charge la
responsabilité et d'assumer le coût de
la mise à l'abri des personnes se
présentant comme mineurs non accompagnés
cette disposition permettra de soulager
les structures de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance le temps d'évaluation de leur
minorité qui doit demeurer du ressort
des départements cet amendement propose
donc la présentation d'un rapport
étudiant une nouvelle répartition des
rôle entre les départements et l'État la
politique migratoire étant une
compétence strictement régalienne alors
je sais qu'ici on apprécie ABS pas les
rapports donc je sais déjà le sort de
cet amendement mais comme on l'a dit
précédemment c'est vraiment une attente
de l'ensemble des département de France
et notamment sur cette loi taqué qui va
interdire tous les jeunes de moins de 16
ans dans les dans les hôtels sociaux et
les départements sont totalement démunis
pour savoir où on va pouvoir les loger
donc j'en appelle véritablement à à une
décision d'urgence et je sais que Madame
cobel A com commencer à y réfléchir mais
j'interpelle également monsieur le
ministre merci il deux amendements
identiques qui c'est qui défend le
282 monsieur
Masset monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues effectivement
dans la même veine même si on se fait
pas trop d'illusion sur cette demande il
quand même important de rappeler que
notre nation est confrontée à une
importante progression du nombre de
mineurs non accompagné
euh à laquelle les départements doivent
faire alors pour Rael au niveau des
département lorsqu'un jeune arrive c'est
à peu près une enveloppe de 500 € qui
est àoué plus 450 € de mise à l'abri
alors que le coût annuel pour un conseil
départemental est d'environ 40000 €.
voilà et sachez que sur un département
rural comme celui de l'otgaronne c'est
une dépense colossale euh et qu' nous
est très très difficile euh d'assumer
donc
euh comme ma collègue on demande
effectivement que l'État prenne en
charge la responsabilité assume le coût
euh de ces personnes mineures non
accompagnées ça permettrait
effectivement de soulager les structures
de la zeu et donc dans cette perspective
nous proposons donc la présentation de
rapport étudiant euh une nouvelle
répartition des rôles entre les
départements et
l'État merci le
494 défendu monsieur
Guay le
137 madame
Boyer merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ben écoutez comme mes
collègues c'est un amendement d'appel
parce que c'est vrai que la situation
des mineurs non accompagné enfin
soi-disant mineurs et soi-disant non
accompagné parce qu'on sait parfaitement
qu'ils sont souvent en proie au trafic
effectivement mais vous le savez ils ont
triplé entre 2016 et
2020 leur nombre a triplé et ces mineurs
sont majoritairement des garçons à 93,2
% âgé de plus de 16 ans pour environ 75
% d'entre eux et avec une proportion de
filles qui augmente de presque 7 % par
rapport à
2021 les MNA représentent aujourd'hui 15
et 20 entre 15 et 20 % des mineurs pris
en charge par laaz et les moyens
consacrés à cette mission par les
départements ont plus que doublé en 20
ans pour atteindre presque 10 milliards
d'euros assumé entièrement par les
départements aussi comme le souhaite
l'Assemblée des départements de France
dans sa résolution du 11 octobre 2023
nous devrions prévoir que l'État prenne
en charge la responsabilité et assume le
coût de la mise à l'abri des personnes
se présentant comme mineurs non
accompagnés afin de soulager les
structures départementales le temps de
l'évaluation de leur minorité
l'évaluation qui doit rester une
compétence des départements mais
malheureusement l'article 40 de notre
Constitution rend irrecevable à tel
amendement c'est pourquoi cet amendement
d'appel prévoit de demander au
gouvernement un rapport sur la prise en
charge des mineurs non accompagnés par
les départ appartement et je voudrais
insister sur une
proposition puisque vous le savez que 90
% des jeunes des jeunes migrants qui se
déclarent mineurs alors qu'en réalité
presque 70 % sont évalués
majeurs et ça ils le savent parce que la
loi taqué comme ça a été dit les
départements ont l'obligation de leur
proposer des contrats jeunes majeurs et
d'assumer leur prise en charge jusqu'à
21 ans ce n'est plus acceptable et je le
répète l'article 40 nous empêche d'agir
mais je formule aujourd'hui une
proposition qui été déclaré irrecevable
cette demande est portée par l'Assemblée
des départements de France et nous vous
demandons d'assumer la responsabilité et
le coût de l'accueil des jeunes migrants
durant la durée de la phase d'évaluation
les départements poursuivrai
l'évaluation de la minorité des MNA et
de prendre en charge ceux qui sont
incontestablement mineurs et de proposer
des contrats jeunes majeurs s'ils le
souhaitent pour les autres cela
s'appelle un partage des charges et des
responsabilité nous ne P on ne peut pas
continuer à procrastiner sur ce
sujet et il faut réviser la loi taquè
merci chers collègues le 78 et le 79
tombent je vais interroger sur le 144
l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues en réalité mon
propos vaudra pour l'ensemble des des
amendements si vous voulez bien monsieur
le Président vous connaissez la
jurisprudence de la commission des lois
madame Darcos l'a dit en commençant
qu'elle n'avait pas d'illusion sur
l'avis que recevrait ses amendements
puisque les demandes de rapport font
effectivement toujours l'objet d'un avis
défavorable pour autant le fond que
révèlent ces amendements est
parfaitement compris de tous puisque
l'association des départements de France
a émis récemment une résolution qui
avait tout d'un appel au secours et nos
collègues que je citais tout à l'heure
dont je citais le rapport messieurs
Bourgi burgois yacovelli et le roi
avaient effectivement dans leur
recommandation inviter monsieur le
ministre à recentraliser à la fois la
mise à l'abri et et l'évaluation de
l'âge des mineurs alors bien évidemment
le Parlement ne peut pas lui seul le
faire en vertu de l'article 40 mais
peut-être pourriez-vous nous dire
quelques mots sur ce point monsieur le
ministre au nom de de du gouvernement et
et indivisible hier vous avez été tour à
tour monsieur dusop et Monsieur du pour
Moretti peut-être pourriez-vous être un
petit peu ce soir Madame
cobel Monsieur le
Ministre madame cobel étant
irremplaçable je ne pourrais le
faire madame D'cos j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure à mite reprise que au même titre
que le Cole de la
nationalité les mineurs ne sont pas dans
ce texte de loi ils ne correspond ni aux
compétences du ministère de l'intérieur
ni et c'est normal à l'action de le
préfectoral et administratif puisque ce
sont les magistrats et on les confie pas
d'ailleurs monsieur le Président si je
peux me permettre puisque j'ai été non
pas président les conseils départemental
on les confie pas au président du
conseil départemental mais au juges
voilà donc je je pense que c'est un
sujet très important comme j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure en réponse à quelques
questions simplement il n pas sa place
me semble-t-il dans ce texteci le fait
même que vous évoquiez des rapports et
pas disposition concrète montre que vous
n'avez sans doute pas su accrocher
législativement disposition mais mais
mais oui ben justement c'est pas moi qui
fait votre commission en plus vous être
majoritaire monsieurci ici si même la
majorité considéré que c'é un article
bon donc voilà il s'agit pas de compéten
directe de ce texte je pense que comme
il nous reste 170 178 amendements et
qu'on a encore toute la simplification
du droit des recours et de l'asile que
nous pourrions peut-être parler du texte
que nous vous présentons et peut-être
plutôt des textes qui vont arriver mais
dont je ne pourrais représenter ici
madame
cobel votre avis monsieur le ministre
défavorable défavorable défavorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements je vais
interroger le 144
il y a une prise de parole demande de
parole monsieur grosvallet
oui merci monsieur le ministre de
rappeler que ce n'est pas l'objet de de
la loi mais puisque le débat est ouvert
et que on ne peut pas laisser dire tout
et n'importe quoi je voudrais dire à
Madame Boyer que la langue française est
bien faite et qu'il y a des adverbes qui
changent le sens même d'une pensée quand
vous dites que les MNA sont souvent au
font des fraudeurs quand parfois ils
utilisent effectivement des moyens pour
pouvoir survivre je voudrais vous dire
que au fond vous êtes influencé par une
pensée dominante il m'est arrivé une
fois d'entendre monsieur
Zemour traiter l'ensemble des MNA de
violeurs de criminel dans la seconde qui
a suivi j'ai porté plainte et cette
plainte a été suivi d'ailleurs par de
nombreux présidents de département qui
plainte qui ont amené monsieur Zemour et
la chaîne de télévision qui l'hébergeit
à être condamné par la justice française
et au fond je me rends compte comment
cette pensée qui ruisselle dans certains
rangs de cette
assemblée font que la pensée dominante
sur une partie de cette assemblée c'est
que avant
les mineurs non accompagnés sont des
fraudeurs alors qu'au regard du droit
français ce sont des
enfants monsieur monsieur
Kai monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'entends bien que l'affaire
des MNA n'est pas strictement c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire dans dans le
texte de loi immigration et je je
rassure monsieur le ministre on a tout
tous dép enfin tous un certain nombre de
d'entre nous ont déposé des amendements
très précis sur la répartition on s'est
tous vu opposer l'article 40 et je vous
rappelle que l'article 40 c'est pas la
majorité ou l'opposition c'est la règle
de la commission des finances et c'est
comme ça donc l'article 40 a fait tomber
l'essentiel des des des amendements
précis là-dessus mais Monsieur le
Ministre au-delà du fait que vous n'êtes
pas vos collègues du gouvernement mais
je suis sû qu'un homme d'influence comme
vous peut leur en parler par conséquent
franchement il y a pas de texte en ce
moment pour raccrocher de manière claire
des amendements à la matière mais ça a
été dit moi je rentre pas dans dans le
débat de
savoir quelle est la réalité des des
choses ou de certains ou pas la vérité
c'est que devant
l'ADF le gouvernement s'est engagé à
clarifier les choses
mais ça remonte à plusieurs mois et
depuis plusieurs mois tous les
présidents de département quelle que
soit leur couleur politique attendent
des mesures voit arriver l'application
de la loi taqué tout de suite et n'ont
toujours pas de répartition faite par le
gouvernement donc c'est pas une question
politique c'est de vous dire au-delà de
tous les tests et tout clarifier les
choses il y a un engagement du
gouvernement auprès de tous les
présidents de département il faut que
cet engagement soit tenu que les
départements sachent exactement comment
il peut faire moi je peux vous dire que
dans le mien département dans les hautes
scelles franchement dans 3
mois si on peut pas loger dans les
hôtels sociaux on va avoir un problème
il y a pas de structure je sais pas ce
qui va se passer donc clairement il faut
que vous le gouvernement pas vous soyez
beaucoup plus clair sur la répartition
madame
Boyer merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement permet juste de dire à notre
collègue que les évaluations pour les
mineurs 70 % sont évalué majeurs donc ça
il y a un rapport du Sénat qui date de
plusieurs années qu'il le dit en tout
cas il était présenté de cette façon
lors de l'examen de la loi colon en 2018
ce que je voulais vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que si on peut pas réviser la loi
taqué moi je vous demande quand est-ce
qu'on peut agir et si nous avons été
nombreux à déposer ce type d'amendement
d'appel dans ce texte c'est parce qu'on
espérait que sur un texte immigration on
est la sujet des des mineurs qui soit
traité et ça fait partie des impensés de
ce texte ça fait partie des trous dans
le gruillire de ce texte qui sont
nombreux et heureusement que le Sénat a
travaillé pour pouvoir compléter ce
texte et faire quelque chose qui réponde
aux besoins des Français je voudrais
aussi aborder frontalement et trouver un
moyen de réguler cette situation au
niveau national parce que demain nous
aurons des présidents de département qui
sont prêts à se mettre hors la loi car
ils ne peuvent plus subir financièrement
cette charge de plus en plus
considérable cela même au détriment des
mineurs en danger parce que c'est ça la
situation aujourd aujourd'hui les
enfants en danger de la zeu on ne peut
plus les accueillir dans les
départements les départements peuvent
pas remplir leurs fonctions et je me
permets de vous inviter à relire
l'excellent article dans Le Figaro d'il
y a 2 jours où la présidente du
département des Bouches du rô Martine
vassal s'exprimait sur le sujet en
disant que ce n'était plus supportable
cette charge n'était plus supportable et
elle a raison et je la soutiens et je me
permets d'être le porte-parole de cette
voix parce que aujourd'hui vous le savez
bien cette situation des mineurs est
hors de contrôle et euh il est
absolument nécessaire je crois qu'on
travaille sur le sur un statut de de ces
mineurs de 16 à 18 ans de ces mineurs
étrangers parce qu'on peut plus
supporter ça dans nos départements et si
demain on a des grosses difficultés avec
les l'enfance en danger qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire on dira qu'on aura rien fait
qu'on les aura abandonné les enfants qui
ont le plus besoin qu'on les aide c'est
ça la réalité aujourd'hui donc c'est pas
un sujet anodin et il faudrait qu'on
trouve une date et que vous preniez s'il
vous plaît monsieur le ministre un an
engagement pour qu'on traite enfin de ce
sujet rapidement merci Monsieur
B monsieur le ministre je ne partage pas
votre point de vue il s'agit d'un
problème qui relève des conditions
d'entrée et de séjour des étrangers ça
n'est pas une génération spontanée cet
afflux de mineurs et de faux mineurs
étrangers qui viennent en France et le
ministre de l'intérieur ne peut pas se
désintéressé d'une situation qui est
caractérisée par une fraude à la loi et
il ne peut d'autant moins s'en
désintéressé que ce sont les
départements collectivités territoriales
dont le suivi relève du ministère de
l'Intérieur et de la Direction générale
des collectivités locales qui assume une
charge qui est en grande partie une
charge indue c'est d'ailleurs si vrai
que c'est une question en réalité
relative au droit d'entrée et de séjours
des étrangers qu'avant la loi taqué un
certain nombre de départements modèles
je peux citer celui de la Manche avait
réussi à écartter un grand nombre de
faux mineurs avec l'aide de ce qu'on
appelait alors la police de l'aide de
l'air et des frontières qui ne se
jugeait pas incompétente elle pour
traiter la question des faux mineurs
police de l'air et des frontières et
médecine légale des hôpitaux ça
permettait d'écarter beaucoup de
fraudeurs qui sont en réalité des
adultes de 25 à 30 ans et qui
souscouvert d'une fausse minorité
s'instalent en France et sont pris en
charge par nos départements vous ne
pouvez pas vous désintéresser de cette
situation parce que vous êtes le
ministre en charge de l'immigration et
parce que vous êtes le ministre en
charge du suivi des collectivités
territoriales
merci Monsieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur bal les décrets pour les nous
interrompons quelques instants débat
autour des MNA les mineurs non
accompagnés vous l'avez vu hein les
sénateurs et bien sont très focalisé sur
ce sujet qui est un grand sujet
d'inquiétude pour les départements et
vous avez entendu également et bien
l'argument du ministre de l'Intérieur et
bien c'est que précisément cela ne le
relève pas de son ministère mais cela
n'a pas empêché le débat d'avoir lieu
dans l'hémicycle on va tout de suite
rejoindre Mathias Arz car on ATT un
autre article important Mathias cet
article c'est l'article 13 qui va
arriver d'ici quelques minutes oui on
sera prochainement à l'article 13 qui
est un article qui prévoit
l'introduction de nouveaux critères
encadrant les titres de séjour fondés
sur le respect des principes de la
République l'absence de menaces grave à
l'ordre public ou encore la résidence
habituelle en France voilà ça c'est un
petit peu le cœur de de cet article mais
la commission l'a largement retravaillé
en créant notamment un contrat
d'engagement au respect des principes de
la République un contrat auquel devront
souscrire tous les étrangers lors d'une
demande ou d'un renouvellement d'un
titre de séjour l'étranger à travers ce
contrat s'engage à respecter la liberté
personnelle la liberté d'expression et
de conscience l'égalité hommes-femme et
à ne pas se prévaloir de ses croyances
ou convictions pour s'affranchir des
règles communes sans quiam aucun titre
de séjour ne sera délivré
merci merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes
ces explications effectivement il y a
beaucoup d'amendements sur cet article
13 article qui ouvre et bien le chapitre
2 de ce projet de loi la chapitre
intitulé mieux tirer les conséquences
des actes des étrangers en matière de
droit au séjour et c'est donc l'un des
débats importants de cette soirée tout
de suite donc retour dans l'hémicycle
qui n'a aucune valeur légale et
réglementaire de l'âge de ces personnes
là de l'âge des gens qui arrivent en
zone d'attente pour savoir en fait s'ils
vont les remettre comme étant aux
Italiens ou s'il vont les accueillir sur
les territoire français en pensant que
c'est des faux mineurs et que du de ce
fait il rentent dans un autre cadre je
suis d'accord donc avec ce que vous
venez de dire c'est pas le rôle du
département de faire ça très clairement
c'est le rôle de l'État parce que ça
concerne bien les politiques
migratoires je vais mettre au voix les
l'amendement numéro 144
qui vote
pour qui vote
contre pas adopté
pour
contre même vote pour le
494 le 137
pour contre il ne sont pas
adopté je suis saisi d'un amendement
numéro 33
madamesu
monsieur monsieur fern je très
ouvert l'article 13 donc de ce projet de
loi conditionne la la délivrance ou le
renouvellement des de séjour un contrat
d'engagement
républicain qui est globalement l'outil
qui maintenant projet lojet loi
s'installe comme comme outil de ciblage
de certaines catégories population de
personne moral jugé suspicieuse et on
l'a eu pendant le on a déjà eu ce débat
pendant la loi séparatisme ce contrat
visait vise toujours les associations et
donc nos arguments seront les
mêmes tout d'abord dans l'esprit même de
cette disposition je ne comprends pas
bien pourquoi on l'intérêt de rédiger un
contrat dont les conditions sont d'ors
et déjà dans la loi et contre
contractualiser le fait de respecter la
loi ça commence à être un peu redondant
et puis sur une question de principe
utiliser la République pour exclure pour
marginaliser c'est un contresens
terrible sur la puissance de notre
modèle républicain et je pense que c'est
une capitulation devant notre capacité à
intégrer merci je vais demander la c'est
bien monsieur
dosuer la l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
l'article 13 tel qu'il a été approuvé
par la commission ne vise pas à exclure
mais au contraire à permettre d'adhérer
au principes de la République au
principes que nous connaissons tous et
au principes que normalement nous
chérissons tous et bien il appartient
aussi aux étrangers de connaître et de
respecter ces principes de la République
et cet article donne une base juridique
solide à la condition d'adhésion au
principe de la République pour délivrer
un titre de séjour c'est donc un avis
défavorable avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre évidemment un avis
de défvorable juste rappeler que le
Conseil d'État a considéré que cette
disposition ne sorte en aucun
cas aux objections constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles c'est-à-dire le fait
vous avez tout à fait compris le sens de
cet article de mettre une obligation de
respect des valeurs de la République
pour les gens qui veulent rester
longtemps sur le territoire national
ainsi après le vote de ce projet de loi
les étrangers qui auront un titre
pluriannuel pourront à la fois justifier
de leur langue française de leur
compréhension langue française et des
valeur de la République sans cela nous
pourrons soit ne pas leur donner le
titre de séjour soit le retirer et donc
effectivement être plus efficace dans la
lutte contre le séparatisme le
communautarisme ou ceux qui ne
respectent pas les valeurs de la
République je rappelle d'ailleurs que
ces notions de valeurs de la République
ont été défini dans la loi séparatisme
que vous avez voté l'année dernière qui
a été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel et validé également dans
plusieurs jurisprudences du Conseil
d'État je donc donne avis de défavorable
aux amendements qui vont toucher cet
article 13 si important
je mets au voix cet article avec deux
avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement
191 Monsieur K merci monsieur le
Président le présent amendement propose
une nouvelle rédaction de l'alinéa 7 par
principe nous ne sommes pas défavorables
à ce que le respect des principes de la
République puisse i la délivrance d'un
titre de séjour mais cela suppose des
exigences et notamment l'exigence que
cet article respecte les principes
constitutionnels et notamment celui
d'intelligibilité et de clarté de la loi
une disposition similaire monsieur le
ministre a déjà été censurée par le
Conseil constitutionnel lors de la loi
séparatisme en effet dans sa décision du
13 août 2021 le Conseil constitutionnel
avait rappelé que l'objectif de ur
constitutionnelle d'accessibilité et
d'intelligibilité de la loi impose au
législateur d'adopter des dispositions
suffisamment précises et des formules
non équivoques il avait estimé que dans
la loi séparatisme le législateur
n'avait pas en faisant référence au
principe de la République sans autre
précision en se bornant à exiger que la
personne étrangère a manifesté un rejet
de ces principes adopter des
dispositions permettant de déterminer
avec suffisamment de précision les
comportements justifiant le refus de
délivrance ou de renouvellement d'un
titre de séjour ou le retrait d'un tel
titre le gouvernement propose
aujourd'hui une nouvelle copie dont nous
doutons qu'elle puisse éviter de nouveau
la censure plusieurs mentions de cet
article 13 ne nous paraissent pas
répondre aux exigences posées par le
Conseil constitutionnel en premier la
notion de liberté personnelle elle n'est
pas suffisamment établi en droit
deuxièmement c'est la même chose
concernant la selon laquelle un étranger
qui sollicite un document de séjour
devra s'engager à ne pas se prévaloir de
ses croyances ou convictions pour
s'affranchir des règles communes
régissant les relations entre les
services publics et les
particuliers quelles sont les règles
communes réagissant les relations entre
les services publics et les particulier
et en quoi se distingue-elle des autres
principes de la République déjà énoncés
dans l'article au regard de ces
incertitudes sur la portée concrète de
ces notions cet amendement propose une
nouvelle rédaction plus conforme aux
exigences d'intelligibilité et clarté de
la
loi merci l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
il est exact que le gouvernement ne
s'est pas contenté de faire référence au
principe de la République mais les a
totalement déterminé ce qui a convenu à
la commission des lois si le Conseil
constitutionnel devait s'en offusquer ce
serait le choc des titans parce que
cette liste elle a été élaborée par le
Conseil d'État ça n'est pas pas
impossible c'est assez improbable en
tout cas nous ça nous a suffisamment
convaincu pour que la vie soit
défavorable monsieur le
[Musique]
ministre merci Madame la rapporteur de
votre soutien c'est tout à fait juste de
quoi s'agit-il en milieu scolaire le P
sensible de signne tenue religieuse bah
effectivement c'est pas très conforme au
principe républicain qu'on appelle la
laïcité que jadis vous défendiez au au
guichet des
services des services publics
l'agression verb d'un agent de
fonctionnaire refus d'être reçu entendu
par un agent de sexe opposé quelqu'un
qui ne veut pas être soigné par un
médecin homme parce que il est lui-même
d'un sexe différent un outrage au
symbole de la République le drapeau
l'imne nationale comm il des
représentations politiques bah oui
lorsque quelqu'un effectivement ne veut
pas se faire soigner par un médecin
parce qu'il un sexe différent pas de la
même religion lorsque quelqu'un ne veut
pas respecter les princip cité lorsque
quelqu'un crache sur notre drapeau
national dans une cérémonie patriotique
oui il ne peut pas rester sur le
territoire national parce qu'on
accueille des gens qui respectent les
règles de la République je crois que
c'est le cas dans la quasi
intégralité des États qui se respectent
on parle de quoi on parle pas de
condamnation pénale on dit juste bah
voilà pas de titre de séjour on peut pas
avoir un titre de séjour lorsqu'on
refuse de se soigner par une femme parce
que c'est une femme alors jadis me
semble-t-il la gauche défendait la
laïcité l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes voilà bon je vois que
désormais c'est pas tout à fait le cas
je le regrette
personnellement merci je mets au
voix madame narassa
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
que vousavez peut-être pas très bien
écouté mon mon collègue k parce que on a
dit à aucun moment qu'on a été contre
l'esprit de cet article et de faire
respecter le contrat républicain on on
veut justement simplement s'assurer que
euh puisque euh les dispositions dans le
passé dans votre loi précédente avaient
été euh retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel parce que c'était ça
n'était pas suffisamment clair euh nous
souhaitons clarifier euh les
dispositions pour qu'ells aient plus de
chances d'être applicable et qu'ell ne
soit plus euh censuré à nouveau par le
Conseil constitutionnel et et et quant à
vos attaques gratuites sur le fait que
les socialistes ne ne défendraient plus
la laïcité j'ai un amendement tout à
l'heure que je défendrai et donc on en
reparlera très
bientôt merci je mets au voix
l'amendement
191 avec deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas
adopté de amendements discussion commune
550 monsieur
ravier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues le contrat
d'intégration républicaine le c est
conclu entre l'État français et tout
étranger non européen admis au séjour en
France souhaitant s'y installer
durablement pour favoriser son insertion
dans la société française or il manque
une mention explicite au respect de la
laïcité dans ce contrat le prosélitisme
islamique issu de l'immigration pose de
nombreux problèmes de
désassimilation
ah ouais mais bon c'est les phénomènes
qui comp qui complexifient la chose puis
à cette heure-ci j'ai du mal et de
trouble à l'ordre publque c'est plus
facile la laïcité c'est à la fois la
discrétion dans l'espace public et la
distinction entre les ordres spirituel
et temporel c'est une conception de la
discrétion oui c'est une conception de
la vie en société propre au pays façonné
par des siècles de christianisme elle
est inconnue d'une grande partie du
monde pour pour éviter les troubles et
justifier le retrait ou le non
renouvellement du titre de séjour il
convient de réaffirmer par cet
amendement la laïcité dans le contrat
d'engagement au respect des principes de
la République auquel sousstcrit
l'étranger
merci amendement 95 monsieur Levi
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le principe
de laïcité est l'un des principes
fondamentaux de notre République il est
important qui figure explicitement dans
le futur contrat d'engagement au respect
des principes de la République or il
n'est pas cité dans la version actuelle
du projet de loi de plus il n'est pas
entièrement recouvert par l'engagement
consistant à ne pas se prévaloir de ces
croyances ou convictions pour
s'afranchir des règles communes
régissant les relations entre les
services publics et les particuliers qui
lui est présent dans le projet de loi
nous proposons donc d'inscrire
explicitement le principe de laïcité au
nombre des engagements inclus dans le
futur contrat merci Madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
je crois que nous sommes d'accord tous
ici pour affirmer que le principe de
laïcité est un des grands principes de
de la République mais comme vous l'avez
indiqué Monsieur ravier dans votre
amendement c'est un principe qui est
inconnu d'une grande partie du monde et
c'est pourquoi il a été totalement
explicité dans cet amendement non pas la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État qui
après tout est est acquise pour l'État
français il n'est nul besoin de de le
rappeler mais dans son autre je dirais
acception euh il est
indiqué
que en France nous avons l'obligation de
ne pas se prévaloir de ses croyances ou
convictions pour s'affranchir des règles
communes régissant les relations entre
les services publics et les particuliers
et c'est précisément la définition de la
laïcité je crois donc que votre demande
ainsi que la demande formulée par
l'amendement 95 et bien est satisfaite
c'est une demande de retrait ou avis
défavorable l'avis du
Gouvernement l'amendement 95 est
retiré donc on va interroger sur
l'amendement
550 les deux amendements sont
retirés on va passer à l'amendement
numéro 267 madame Nara cigin
[Musique]
oui alors nous allons continuer sur ce
ce thème de la
laïcité monsieur le ministre s'il y a
une chose dont les socialistes peuvent
s'en orgueillir c'est que depuis 1905
ils ont toujours soutenu la laïcité
défendu le principe de laïcité et c'est
justement pour cela que nous estimons
que dans la rédaction actuel de de
l'article
13 cette notion n'est pas suffisamment
bien explicite C et que c'est pour cela
que nous nous proposons d'insérer les
mots les dispositions de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 concernant la séparation
des Églises et de l'État applicable au
particulier parce que dans cette loi de
1905 il y a notamment son article 31 qui
sanctionne le fait de faire pression sur
un individu pour exercer ou s'abstenir
de pratiquer un culte c'est un article
qui n'est pas suffisamment appliqué dans
la République et et il nous paraissait
important de le
réaffirmer merci l'avis de la
commission la commission a émis un avis
de retrait ou ou avis défavorable
précisément parce que ce que ce que vous
invoquez ma cher collègue ça s'appelle
la liberté de conscience et ça figure
expressément dans les principes qui sont
énumérés monsieur le
ministre je pense que y compris pour les
débats que va lire le Conseil
constitutionnel peut-être peut-on
définir très rapidement ce qu'est la la
laïcité et comment on l'entend parce que
sinon on s'y perd madame la sénatrice il
me semble que laïcité c'est ces trois
choses reconnues désormais depuis très
longtemps notre droit d'abord c'est un
principe de neutralité de la part de
l'état de la part de l'État et de ses
serviteurs d'abord de ces fonctionnaires
et des gens qui travaillent en tant
qu'agent public ils n'ont pas à montrer
évidemment leur croyan religieuse par en
faire la promotion et ça vaut aussi pour
leur raisonnement politique ou syndical
mais en tout cas là pour la citer une
question évidemment religieuse c'est le
fait que l'État ne préfère aucun culte
ça veut pas dire d'ailleurs qu'il ne
peut pas non ça veut pas dire qu'il ne
ne peut pas les ici ou là les aider il
peut le faire dans le cadre de la
sécurité on subventionne par exemple des
caméras de vidéprection pour les cultes
et puis aujourd'huiésormais l'accession
au handicap mais ça veut dire qu'on ne
subventionne pas et d'ailleurs je
constate que le Conseil constitutionnel
ne l'a jamais d'ailleurs
constitutionnalisé ce qui d'ailleurs
pose une question euh sur ce que entend
exactement la loi de la répu Rpublique
comme principe fondamental de la
République et troisièmement il y a une
liberté de culte et notamment
d'expression religieuse notamment dans
le domaine public on entend souvent
qu'il faut cacher ses appartenances
religieuses dans le sur le domaine
public c'est évidemment le contraire de
la laïcité lacité c'est la permission
justement d'exprimer puisque l'article
10ation des droit de l'homme prévoit que
on peut on peut présenter ses opinions
même religieuses le même étant montrant
sans doute qu'elles sont par nature
dangereuse sans doute ses opinions pour
les révolutionnaires de 1789 donc c'est
la neutralité des agences la liberté de
culte et donc évidemment de ne pas
croire en même temps de pouvoir exprimer
ses convictions religieuses y compris
sur le domaine public et c'est
évidemment la question de de son
subventionnement la laïcité bien sûr
qu'il faut la respecter ce qui ne serait
pas respectable en effet c'est une
pression sur les uns ou sur les autres
ou un agent qui voudrait montrer un
agent du service public bien évidemment
qui voudrait montrer son opinion
religieuse mais la laïcité c'est aussi
des règles qui ont conduit à la
neutralité notamment des des lieux où
les enfants vont à l'école tout
simplement et donc le fait de pouvoir de
façon répétée à l'école publique vouloir
être dans l'opposition à notre principe
de la laïcité qui à la fois l'expression
publique religieuse dans le domaine
public mais aussi l'accept l'acceptation
de la neutralité des agents de l'État et
de certains lieux qu'on qualifie de
sanctuaire républicain qui est l'école
publique bah il me semble que ça doit
être sanctionné voilà on ne peut pas
sansprendre à quelqu'un qui dans la rue
porte un vêtement religieux s'il
respecte les règles de la République on
ne peut pas en tant qu'agent public
revendiquer ou contractuel revendiquer
une opinion religieuse et on ne peut pas
violenter les règles fondamentales de la
République et la laïcité et donc la
neutralité pour les agents comme pour
les les enfants de neutralité religieuse
alors après moi je suis très heureux
madame la satrice d'entendre que le
Parti socialiste revient à la règle de
1905 il m'a pas paru ces dernières
années que c'était tout à fait le cas
que n'alz-vous voter queavez-vous voté
queavez-vous voté un cens de disposition
qu'on vous a présenté mais chacun le
sait chacun chacun le sait chacun le
voit il y a encore mais il y a encore
heureusement des laïques il y a encore
heureusement des laïques au Parti
socialiste mais pour pour il y en a
encore il y en a encore j'imagine je
l'espère mais en tout cas
majoritairement les alliances avec
Monsieur Mélenchon ne permettent pas de
penser vous êtes désormais les
défenseurs absolu de la laïcité donc
voilà assumez vos assumez assumez
assumez les alliances politiques que
vous avez avec des gens qui
manifestement donne des coups à cela
voilà mais c'est pas grave on peut le
dire non mais voilà donc je pense qu'on
peut le dire voilà je pense qu'on peut
dire et vous le savez non c'est pas
inutile vousmême vous faites Paragon de
vertu simplement vous n'êtes pas très
propre président rot
oui simplement je voudrais redire
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
que cet article 13 doit beaucoup
pour deux raisons il lui doit beaucoup
d'abord parce que dans le respect des
principes de la publique la loi
séparatisme l'amendement qui avait posé
le principe que l'on pouvait retirer un
titre de séjour ou le refuser lorsque
l'individu ne respectait pas les
principes de la République avait été
déposé et voté ici à l'initiative de
Roger carucci et de votre serviteur il
avait été ensuite voté à l'assemblée et
censuré le 13 août 2021 par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui avait indiqué le
respect des principes de la République
c'est trop flou et vous reprenez
évidemment pour tenter de enfin à juste
titre d'ailleurs d'expliciter première
chose donc il est né ici cet article est
n ici deuxième chose la laïcité rendons
à César ce qui est à César à
l'initiative de philiba nous avions voté
un article d'une
PPLC qui était la définition qui
s'applique non pas à l'état mais à
chaque citoyen et qui voulait dire nul
ne peut se prévaloir de ses origines de
ses croyances pour s'affrangir de la
règle commune souvenez
nous l'avions voté ici et c'est ce qui
est repris et je pense que pour avoir
les idées claires sur la laïité la
laïité c'est à la fois le devoir de
l'État de ne pas subventionner la
neutralité mais là on n pas sur ce
volant là de laité on est sur le volant
des citoyens qui soit étranger
d'ailleurs peu importe et ça c'est une
définition que avec philiba nous avions
reprise qui a donné le Conseil
constitutionnel de la laïcité
s'appliquant à nos concitoyens de 2004
donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
ferme et qui correspond justement au
devoir pour la laïcité de chaque citoyen
la laïcité c'est cet équilibre il y a
des devoirs qui concernent l'État mais
il y a aussi des devoirs qui concernent
chaque citoyen et vous avez là la
définition de la laïcité pour la partie
qui concerne chaque citoyen qui soit
étranger ça n'est pas le cas quand il
étranger n'est pas citoyen mais aussi
pour chaque Français bravo
merci je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement
qui vote contre qui vote
pour
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
j'ai été saisi de neuf amendements en
discussion commune dont quatre
amendements identiques le 44 c'est
Madame
Boyer très rapidement monsieur le
Président puisque cet amendement je me
permets de le rappeler est issu du
projet de loi déposé par les députés
sénateurs les républicains pour
reprendre le contrôle de l'immigration
et l'intégration et l'asile projet qui a
été déposé en juin 2023 et il a
introduit de nouveaux critères de
retrait des titres de séjour qui sont
fondés sur deux choses euh l'existance
d'une menace grave à l'ordre public et
le défaut de résidence habituelle en
France parce que c'est vrai que la
sauvegarde de l'ordre public est quelque
chose d'absolument essentiel je vous
remercie merci Madame Darcos
oui il est similaire au précédent mais
je défends quand même cet amendement de
mon collègue Louis Vogel le distingo
immigration subit immigration choisie
n'est plus complment complètement
opérant du point de vue juridique notre
cadre normatif notamment le poids des
textes protégeant la vie privée et
familiale est tel que notre capacité à
choisir les flux migratoires est limitée
il faut donc éviter les formules qui
nous exposent au procès en impuissance à
cette dicotomie la Commission et nos
rapporteurs ont choisi avec justesse et
pertinence l'ambition d'une immigration
maîtrisée qui oblige pour reprendre le
contrôle à s'interroger sur chacun des
flux deimmigration et en identifier les
leviers et les moyens dont nous pouvons
disposer pour utiliser ou pas selon les
choix politiques chacun d'eux l'alinéa 9
de cet article prévoit ainsi que aucun
document de séjour ne peut être délivré
à un étranger qui refuse de souscrire à
l'engagement républicain dans la même
finalité il semble nécessaire comme le
soulligne cet amendement dans la lignée
des options retenues par nos rapporteurs
que l'absence de renouvellement et le
retrait éventuel du titre de séjour de
l'étranger qui méconnaîtrait son
engagement républicain soit non pas une
possibilité mais une
certitude
madame qui c'est qui présente hashiman
ou
Martin défendu de 6 632 madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
il
s'agit pour le préfet lorsqu'il est dans
l'occurrence d'une délivrance d'un
document de séjour d'un renouvellement
ou d'un retrait lorsqu'il constate le
non respect par un étranger du contrat
d'engagement au principe de la
République ou lorsque l'étranger
constitue une menace pour l'ordre
publique et bien d'être dans une
situation de compétence liée pour
s'opposer à la délivrance au
renouvellement ou au retrait de ce titre
de
séjour merci
306 Monsieur
bénaroche Merci monsieur monsieur le
Président il s'agit d'une suppression
d'un certain nombre d'alinéas prévus à
l'article 13 en particulier donc la
suppression de ces alinéa aurit pour
conséquence d'exclure la condition d'une
résidence en France effective et
habituelle pour le renouvellement d'une
carte de séjour
pluriannuelle l'article 13 définit la
résidence habituelle comme un séjour
d'au moins 6 mois au cours de l'année
civile des milliers de personnes qui
vivent entre deux pays pourraient aini
seevir refuser le renouvellement de leur
titre de séjour alors qu'il faudrait que
les politiques migratoires favorisent
une liberté de circulation
d'aller-retour pour mieux épouser les
besoins et les réalités de certaines
personnes étrangère l'option prise est
contraire au gel et à l'immobilisme
cette condition risque d'entraîner des
personnes dans une situation juridique
très instable il s'agit en l'occurrence
d'une anème condition qui n'a qu'un seul
but qui est de restreintre toujours plus
les droits des personnes à résider en
France dans des conditions de vie
stables merci le 441 monsieur
Guay merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 13 du texte modifié en
Commission prévoit notamment de
conditionner à une résidence habituelle
en France le renouvellement d'une carte
de séjour pluri annuelle un bénéficiaire
d'une telle carte pourrait ne pas se
l'avoir renouvelé s'il n'a pas transféré
en France le centre de ses intérêts
privés et familiaux et s'il n'y sijourne
pas au moins 6 mois chaque année pendant
les trois dernières années précédant le
dépôt de la demande de renouvellement
rappelons que cette carte de séjour
pluriannuelle n'est délivrée qu'après
une carte de séjour temporaire ou un
visa de long séjour valant titre de
séjour son renouvellement est déjà
soumis au respect d'une série
d'obligations notamment en matière
d'intégration et de domiciliation en
France or parmi les raisons pour
lesquelles le législateur est intervenu
en vue de développer son caractère
pluriannuel des titres il y a un motif
de simplification de diminution de la
récurrence des renouvellements et donc
des déplacements en préfecture
une telle proposition irait donc à
l'encontre de cette tendance législative
de simplification le délai d'instruction
de la demande de renouvellement
augmentera fortement comme le soulligne
l'étude d'impact là où un unique
justificatif de domicile éta requis
plusieurs pièces devront désormais être
examinées à minima une trentaine une
telle condition risque de pénaliser des
personnes étrangère qui vivent
alternativement entre la France et leur
pays ce qui n'est pas souhaitable je
vous remercie
mer
635 madame la rapporteur coordination
monsieur
président
613 je le retire au bénéfice du 636
madame Jorda qui poursuit les mêmes
objectifs mais qui à mon avis est mieux
rédigé que sueli du
gouvernement retirer le
alors le 636 est tellement bien rédigé
qu'il va être facilement résumé il
s'agit de précision sur le régime de
l'expulsion des titaires d'une carte de
de résident en réalité qui ne pourront
pas faire l'objet d'une qtf ceci pour
permettre de rassurer le Conseil
d'État vous êtes là madame la rapporteur
va donner un avis
sur les
amendements alors les amendements numéro
44 de Madame Boyer 102 de Monsieur Vogel
64 de Monsieur Dufour sont identiques à
l'amendement de la commission numéro 632
c'est donc un avis favorable à ces trois
amendements les amendements 306 et de
Monsieur béaroch et 441 de Monsieur
brossa reviennent sur un apport de
l'article 13 qui est venu conditionner
comme vous savez le renouvellement des
cartes de résidence et des cartes de
séjour plriannuel à une résidence
habituelle en France c'est une une
décision qui avait été approuvé par la
commission et et c'est donc un avis
défavorable le l'amendement 636 je vous
l'ai présenter c'est le nôtre il est
évident que nous y tenons et je prends
note de ce que le gouvernement a retiré
son
[Musique]
amendement c'est
bon monsieur le ministre
oui c'est un avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble des amendements SAU celui
pour lequel je suis retiré en faveur de
Madame Jourda alors ceux qui sont
déposés
notamment par la gauche je sais pas ce
qu'il viennent détricoter la mesure de
l'article 13 et ceux qui sont déposés
notamment par soit madame Jorda soit
monsieur Dufour soit par Madame
Boyer et Monsieur Vogel c'est le fait
que vous ne laissez pas pardon de
revenir à l'article 3 ou l'article 4 bis
mais vous ne laissez pas le pouvoir
d'appréciation du préfet vous faites
compéten lié donc ce qui valait pour la
régularisation ce qui vaer pour la
sanction administrative à mon avis vaut
aussi pour le retrait de jour laisser le
préfet à partir il a des règles de voir
s'il y a des cas euh exceptionnels qui
peuvent être traités humainement bon
voilà donc je pense que lié la
compétence direct du préfet d'abord ne
sera pas à mon avis constitutionnel mais
indépendamment de ça permettrait
j'imagine de respecter les haut
fonctionnaires qui vont évidemment
apprécer sur le terrain la nouvelle le
nouvel esprit voulu par le législateur
donc un avis défavorable à l'ensemble
sauf à celui de Madame Jourda que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure le
636 plzy madame la RA merci monsieur le
Président juste à mot de réponse à
monsieur le ministre c'est effectivement
une compétence liée mais le préfet garde
toute compétence tout de même pour
apprécier les manquements au principe de
la
République voilà nous allons mettre au
voie les quatre amendements identiques
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre ils ne sont pas
adoptés ils sont adoptés excusez-moi ils
sont
adoptés je mets au voix l'amendement
306 qui vote
pour alors avis défavorable de la
commission et défavorable pour du
gouvernement qui vote
[Musique]
pour qui vote
contre pas
adopté 40
441 avis défavorable de la commission
défavorable du
gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre n'est pas adopté
635 avis favorable de la
commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre n pas
adopté le
636 ça y est c'est
fait je suis
saisi
600 le
636 avis favor
de la commission av favorable du
gouvernement qui c'est qui vote pour qui
vote favorable de la commission
favorable du gouvernement qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est
adopté 5 amendements en discussion
commune
351 Monsieur
Bonhomme merci monsieur le président le
cet amendement vise à faciliter la
caractérisation des ruptures de contrat
d'engagement au principe au respect des
principes de la République prévu
l'article 13 or en l'état du texte le
manquement entraînant la rupture du
contrat résulte d'agissement délibéré de
l'étranger troublant l'ordre public les
manquements au principe de la République
ne s'accompagnent pas systématiquement
de trouble à l'ordre publ c'est pourquoi
le président amendement juge donc
opportun de reprendre ici les
dispositions de la proposition de loi
pour reprendre le contrôle de la
politique migratoire d'intégration et
d'asile rendant le critère de trouble à
l'ordre public
facultatif 633 madame la rapporteur
c'est le même amendement monsieur le
Président passer à l'amendement
88 présente Madame
Boyer merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit d'un amendement porté par madame
borquot fontin et ses collègues et qui
est tout simple puisqu'il souhaite
supprimer à l'alinéa 10 le mot grave en
effet la définition de la gravité
peut-être très variable et les derniers
événements ont démontré que parfois le
laxisme judiciaire peut avoir des
juridique pardon peut avoir des
conséquences dramatiques et d'ailleurs
pourquoi attendre attendre que les
atteintes à nos valeurs et à nos
principes les plus fondamentaux soient
graves alors que dès leur existence ces
atteintes doivent justifier d'un
principe de précaution vis-à-vis de des
de nos concitoyens des choses comme le
respect de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes la laïcité ou encore la
liberté de conscience ne sont pas des
choix de société mais des obligations
pour être incorporés dans la société
française et donc cet amendement vise
donc à considérer que certaines
atteintes jugées peut-être pas graves ou
simples ne peuvent pas donner droit à un
titre de
séjour merci le 352 Monsieur
Bonhomme
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement a pour objet de faciliter la
caractérisation des ruptures de contrat
d'engagement au respect des principes de
la République prévu l'article 13
précisément il prévoit que la condition
de gravité des agissements constitue un
manquement au principe de la République
qui figure au à l'article 13 est présumé
constitué en cas d'atteinte aux droits
et liberté d'autrui madame la
rapporteur pour le
634 pour le 634 qui est identique à
l'amendement qui vient d'être présenté
monsieur tout à fait votre avis sur ces
amendements alors l'amendement 351 de
madame Dumont est conforme à
l'amendement 633 de la commission c'est
donc un avis favorable l'amendement de
Madame borquio Fontain qui vise à
supprimer le caractère grave de la
condition de gravité pour caractériser
un manquement au contrat d'engagement
euh et bien me semble et déjà satisfait
par les deux amendements que qui
viennent d'être êre évoqué c'est donc
une demande de retrait au profit des
amendements précédents sinon un avis
défavorable et s'agissant de
l'amendement numéro 352 de madame Dumont
et bien il est conforme à l'amendement
de la commission 634 c'est donc un avis
favorable monsieur le ministre
oui madame la président monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur je je
suis un peu embêté parce que je je
partage l' de votre amendement 633 et et
du reste des autres peut-être à
l'exception du 634 qui me paraît un peu
un peu lointain mais le 633 ne serait
d'après ce que je comprends rendrait la
la disposition peut-être contraire à la
Constitution selon à la fois le Conseil
d'État mais surtout les jurisprudances
du Conseil constitutionnel s'appuyant
notamment sur l'article 10 de la DDHC et
et donc je crain que elle a aille un peu
trop loin et elle nous empêche peut-être
d'avoir la disposition de la l'article
13 comme nous le souhaitions donc moi je
j'attire votre attention j'atention de
l'Assemblée sur le fait qu'elle n'est
pas conforme au jance du Conseil
constitutionnel donc comme je tiens à la
mesure de l'article 13 que nous avons
évoqué depuis tout à l'heure je donne un
avis défavorable sur l'ensemble des des
amendements mais particulièrement je
voudrais dire sur le
633 très bien je mets au
voie l'amendement 351 avec un avis
favorable de la
et nous interrompons quelques instants
les débats sur le projet de loi
immigration qui porte sur l'article 13
précisément car nous sommes avec le
président de la commission des lois
François Noël buffet bonsoir bonsoir
François Noël buffet il y a eu deux
articles
importants qui ont été adoptés cet
après-midi notamment les articles qui
permettent d'expulser plus facilement
les étrangers qui représentent une
menace grave à l'ordre public le
ministre de les de l'intérieur les a
notamment présenter et cela avant même
que l'on débatte de ce projet de loi
comme des réponses après l'attentat
d'aras que pensez de cette défense du
ministre de l'intérieur de ce texte
écoutez il faut redire quel est l'état
d'esprit général du texte c'estàd qu'en
matière soit d'immigration irrégulière
soit de comportements qui sont
parfaitement par des étrangers
naturellement parfaitement contraire à
ce que nous attendons d'un comportement
normal et en particulier lorsqu'une
dangerosité est parfaitement ébl et bien
qu'il ne puisse pas rester sur le
territoire ça reste quand même un
principe donc il fallait que le texte le
permette le texte le permettra c'est une
défense de circonstances tout de même
sur ce projet de loi d'insi le lier à un
acte terroriste sur le territoire
français c'est pas une défense de
circonstances c'est
malheureusement une question comment
comment comment dire c'est une nécessité
d'avoir cet outils juridiques pour
pouvoir mener une action efficace face à
de telle
situation et je crois que
malheureusement les circonstances si on
veut être vont être vont se continuer en
tous les cas ces mauvaises circonstances
nous le savons les menaces sont très
fortes la violence est extrêmement forte
elle n'est pas tolérable de sur quoi
elle est encore moins tolérable
lorsqu'elle vient de quelqu'un qui est
étranger au pays et qui ne peut pas
rester sur le territoire national c'est
le minimum quand même on a vu hein la
droite qui a apporté un certain nombre
de d'urcissement de signes de fermeté
sur ce projet de loi he de la mise en
place de quotas M atoire à la
transformation de laame en aide médicale
d'urgence qu'est-ce qui va rester de
tout cela à la fin de l'examen de ce
texte après la navette écoutez je ne
suis pas devin ce qui était important et
ce qui est important nous y sommes
encore c'est que le Sénat a un texte que
le texte voté au Sénat soit celui qui
corresponde à la volonté de la majorité
sénatoriale et qu'il est estce c'est un
texte d'affichage pour la drite non pas
du tout c'est pas un texte d'affichage
les mesures qui ont été votées qui sont
dans le texte son les mesures que nous
défendons depuis longtemps ce qui est
nouveau j'allis presque dire pour ça
c'est la cohérence de
l'ensemble on fait en réalité on écrit
au Sénat une stratégie en matière de
politique migratoire pour le pays nous
verrons bien ce qu'il adviendra après
nous ne sommes pas comptable de ce qui
se passera à l'Assemblée nationale mais
il apparaît très clair que l'Assemblée
nationale devra prendre ses
responsabilités et que devant le texte
devant la réalité de celui-ci la réalité
du vote et des mesures qui sont dans le
texte l'Assemblée nationale devra
prendre ses responsabilités on verra
bien parce qu'il est pas le tout d'avoir
des mots des déclarations des grandes
déclarations il y a un moment il faudra
voter vous pens qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui peuvent y rester que ce soit
via un 493 si la première ministre et
bien finit par ne pas avoir de majorité
elle choisira ce qu'elle voudra soit en
commission mixte paritaire ça va
demander quand même une grosse
négociation pour pouvoir faire passer
nous savons que ça demandera une grosse
négociation mais il faut déjà franchir
l'étape de l'Assemblée nationale avant
la CMP donc attendons d'abord finissons
le texte au Sénat l'Assemblée nationale
devra se prononcer moi je serais très
attentif à ce qui va se passer parce que
des déclarations on en a tous les jours
aujourd'hui mais lorsque le gouvernement
affiche une volonté de fermeté en
singulièrement le ministre affiche cette
volonté de de fermeté voilà disons les
choses telles qu'elles sont et que de
Cro il trouve dans le texte du Sénat
cette fermeté qu'il revendique lui-même
et bien il faudra bien que l'Assemblée
nationale se positionne mais ça va ça va
être à la fois très très très
intéressant euh les débats l'assemblée
vont être très intéressant et
politiquement intéressant aussi un
dernier mot François nel buffet sur et
bien l'article qui est en train d'être
discuté dans l'hémicycle cet article qui
a été modifié par la commission qui a
notamment créé un contrat d'engagement
au respect des principes de la
République pour qu'un étranger puisse
avoir un titre de séjour hein c'est
copié de la loi sur le séparatisme on a
entendu notamment la gauche qui avait
des craintes notamment sur la dimension
constitutionnelle vous n'avezun e cte là
non non aucune crainte absolument aucune
crainte d'abord parce que le Tex sur
lesvaleurs de la République nous l'avons
voté euh il a pas été sanctionné nous
faisons référence à celui-ci et on
estime que dans les conditions pour
obtenir un titre de séjour il faut aussi
respecter Lesur de la République
c'est-à-dire ce que nous sommes ce que
nous défendons qu'on ne peut pas venir
ici pour les contester par principe
voire même les combattre et que les
choses doivent être claires quand vous
allez dans n'importe quel pays dans le
monde bah vous respectez les valeurs de
que que ce pays exige voilà on est plus
ou moins content mais on les respecte et
on est dans ce cadre là donc nous avons
bien raison de le mettre et je pense il
y a aucun problème en tout les cas je ne
vois pas à ce stade des difficultés
constitutionnelle et bien merci beaucoup
françalif d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vous laisse rejoindre la
séance tout comme nous retour donc dans
l'hémicycle et c'est guibénaroche qui
est en train de s'exprimer effectivement
on pourrait demander à ces mères là ce
qu'il pent des immigrés et des étrangers
qui sont sur leur territoire mais
pourquoi lier cette interrogation au
fait que systématiquement il faut la
rendre confidentielle parce que
forcément les maires vont donner des
informations qui sont des informations
qui consistent à dire Hel pourra pas
être intégré ça me surprend
quoi merci personne on va mettre au voix
cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote pour qui vote
contre il n'est pas
adopté amendement 598 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui c'est un amendement important que
j'évoqué dans la discussion générale
monsieur le Président il s'agit de quoi
il s'agit lorsque quelqu'un qui avait
l'asile était réfugié il a été démontré
qu'il repartait dans son pays notamment
lorsquil a reparté par exemple en
vacances alors qu'il avait demandé
l'asile justement parce qu'il serait
persécuté dans son pays et que le lui a
retiré son asile ce qui est déjà prévu
il n'était pas prévu par la loi lu
retire aussi sa carte de résidence son
titre de séjour ce qui fait qu'il y
avait des gens qui avent pu avoir
l'asile en France avoir un titre de
séjour parce qu'ils avaient l'asile en
France on l'a retiré leur asile parce
qu'ils repartaient dans leur pays
d'origine où là ils étaient censés
persécuté alors qu'il n'y était pas
persécuté puisqu'il y retourné mais on a
gardé tout en retirant l'asile un titre
de séjour évidemment c'est assez
incompréhensible pour les français et
même pour les services que cela puisse
continuer ainsi donc cette amend
monsieur le Président vise à retirer à
tirer toutes les conséquences du retrait
de l'asile et donc de retirer le titre
de séjour pour pouvoir expulser
évidemment cette personne ou l'éloigner
si elle est sur le territoire national
malgré cela merci l'avis de la
commission favorable monsieur le
Président avis favorable de la
commission pas de prise de parole je
mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre
adopté amendement 4
179 monsieur
Bouis merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement est un amendement
d'harmonisation rédactionnelle avec les
autres dispositions du projet de loi
nous proposons en effet d'ajouter à
l'alinéa 18 de l'article 13 le mot grave
après le mot
menace merci l'avis de la commission
favorable avis du
gouvernement deux avis favorables qui
vote pour il vote contre il est adopté
chers collègues je vais mettre au voix
l'article
13 de prise de parole qui vote je mets
au voix qui vote pour l'article 13 qui
vote contre l'article 13 qui s'abstient
l'article 13 est adopté je suis saisi
d'un amendement du Gouvernement le 614
monsieur le
ministre passer par la zo euh et on
interrompt c'est l'examen du projet de
loi immigration alors que vous l'avez vu
he l'article 13 qui prévoit notamment
après modification par la commission un
contrat d'engagement au respect des
principes de la République he pour les
étranger pour la délivrance d'un titre
de séjour et bien vous l'avez vu cet
article a donc été adopté tout de suite
je suis avec Jérôme Durin bonjour sateur
socialiste Jérôme Durin tout d'abord un
mot et bien sur un volet fermeté qui a
été adopté aujourd'hui pour faciliter
l'expulsion des étrangers qui
représentent une menace grave à l'ordre
public qu'est-ce que vous inspire et
bien l'adoption de ces mesures qui
étaient parmi les mesures importantes
présentées notamment comme une réponse
après l'attentat d'aras écoutez nous
nous estimons que ces mesures
n'apportent pas une
clarification majeure à la situation que
connaît le pays et d'ailleurs quand on
s'intéresse à la question euh de
l'apport concret de ces mesures une
situation du type aras on n pas persuadé
que ça aurait changé fondalement les
choses on estime plutôt d'ailleurs avec
mes collègues spéalist pas facilité
parce que on dit le droit est compliqué
énormément le fait d'expulser un une
personne qui est arrivée mineur avant 13
ans parce que là cette protection est
quand même modifiée avec avec ce texte
le ministre de l'Intérieur revendique
une clarification nous ne la voyons pas
si évidente que ça et on trouve que
finalement c'est un avis personnel aussi
que que j'apporte depuis le début de ce
texte il y a quand même beaucoup
d'idéologie et on voit que les vieilles
lunes de la droite sénatoriale et de la
majorité sénatoriale irigent beaucoup
nos débats donc difficulté d'intégration
on l'a vu hier sur le groupement
familial sur laame méical d'État
aujourd'hui on continue avec ses mesures
les fameux principes de la République
qui c'est sont des notions floues et
donc quand il y a l'idéologie on fait
pas du bon droit il n semble que
l'apport législatif de ces articles
n'est pas très clair pas la première
fois sur l'immigration vu le nombre de
textes qui ont été adoptés depuis trois
décennies ce sont souvent des textes
avec une dimension très politique
d'affichage aussi g ça depuis toujours
bien sûr mais c'est évident il suffit de
regarder d'ailleurs le dérouleur qui
nous permet de travailler dans
l'hémicycle beaucoup d'amendements sont
signés par Monsieur Rav
zmouristes des gens du rassemblement
national et la droite parlementaire donc
il y a une chose très simple un
mouvement très simple un déport à droite
de l'ensemble du débat
politique le rassemblement national qui
tire très fort sur l'immigration LR suit
le rassemblement national et le
gouvernement qui est un peu obligé de
faire avec ce mouvement bah nous nous
nous opposons parce que nous considérons
question est-ce que ça correspond
aujourd'hui bien aussi à ce que pense à
ce qu'attendent les Français en terme de
message de fermeté sur l'immigration moi
je veux bien qu'on ait des messages de
fermeté et vous savez que le groupe
socialiste écologgiste et républicains
ici est particulièrement ferme sur la
lopmie les moyens du ministère de
l'intérieur on n'a pas barguigné notre
soutien on était là donc il s'agit pas
d'un d'un sujet de fermeté il s'agit
d'un sujet d'efficacité alors les gens à
l'extérieur disent il faut de la fermeté
on les comprend la droite ici dit on va
être ferme très bien mais ici notre
boulot à nous législateur c'est de
vérifier que ce qu'on vote est conforme
à ce qu'on annonce en l'espèce il y a un
écart entre les deux il y a aussi eu un
assez long moment de débat autour des
MNA les mineurs non accompagnés tout à
l'heure euh c'est intéressant parce que
c'était peut-être un un des moments où
il y a eu le plus de débats dans
l'hémicycle pour que finalement on nous
dise bah les mineurs non accompagnés ils
n'ont rien à faire dans ce texte ils
n'ont rien à faire avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur ce n'est pas le sujet
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce débat que
l'on a vu toute fois dans l'émiss non
mais il y a une vraie demande autour des
des mil acccompagnés d'ailleurs il y a
une sollicitation des des départements
qui doivent gérer cette situation et et
administrativement on voit que c'est
compliqué en revanche vous demandez-vous
aussi cette
recentralisation à l'évidence il faut
bouger en revanche c'est c'est c'est un
une des limites du texte c'est qu'on
vient y mettre beaucoup de choses qui
sont dans l'actualité et dont le
périmètre initial du texte ne voulait
pas je pense aussi la situation de
régularisation mais vous étiez pour pour
pour pour le coup oui parce que tout le
monde voilà c'est on on saisit la perche
qui est tendu mais effectivement c'est
une des limites de de ce débat qui n'est
pas d'une certaine manière fructueux je
pense aussi la régularisation des jeunes
mineurs des jeunes majeurs passés par
laaz l'aide sociale à l'enfance c'est un
texte que j'avais porté moi il y a
quelques années c'est tous ces gamins
qui sont dans les boulangeries dans chez
les artisans locaux et qui travaillent
qui ont suivi une formation qui ont
coûté à la société sur lesquell on
investit qui qui sont eux-mêmes intégrés
et puis à qui ont dit du jour au
lendemain c'est fini au qtf quitait le
territoire français voilà nous on disait
que c'est une mesure les mesures
d'efficacité ça aurait été de
régulariser nous nous ne craignion pas
l'appel d'air en revanche ceuxl si on
les met dehors ils vont manquer à
l'économie française et c'est ce que
nous disent les patrons et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que réclament les
parlementaires même de droite quand dans
leur permanence ils reçoivent ces
boulangers ces petits patrons ces
artisans qui ont besoin de cette main
d'œuvre donc il faut être pragmatique et
moins idéologue une toute dernière
question sur le fait que Géral d'manin a
fait valoir quand même ce soir qu'il y
avait eu une mesure comment dire qui
pourrait être qualifié de jambe gauche
pour
le fait qu' les mineurs de moins de 16
ans ne pourront plus être en centre de
rétention administrative est-ce que ça
c'est quand même une avancée du texte
oui c'est c'est y a au fil des articles
et au fil des amendements il y a quand
même de temps en temps quelques rares
bonnes nouvelles considérons que
celle-là en est une bien merci beaucoup
Jérôme Durin d'avoir répondu à mes
questions tout de suite on reprend la
direction de l'hémicycle de rendre
visite à ses enfants étudiants en France
quand on empêche à des jeunes motivés
qui souhaitaent partir faire des études
en France de le faire que crét-on et
bien on crée une amertune une déception
envers notre pays quand on empêche un
entrepreneur de venir faire des affaires
en France que se passe-t-il il ira faire
des affaires et trouver des débouchés
ailleurs quand on empêche des artistes
parfois à renommé nationale ou
internationale de se produire en France
que fait-on encore une fois on affaiblit
le rayonnement culturel de la France
derrière les chiffres derrière les
réductions de 30 50 % d'octroit de visa
comme on l'a déjà connu au Maghreb il y
a un ou de ans il y a des familles des
vies des projets qui sont bloqués pour
des raisons politique ou géopolitique
sur lesquels ils n'ont aucune prise pour
C ces raisons nous dénonçons les
stratégies tant du gouvernement que de
la majorité sénatorial dans le
traitement de la politique des visas et
demandons ainsi la suppression de cet
article
merci madame Richard pour
429 merci monsieur le Président je vais
tenir à peu près les mêmes propos les
cette cette réforme de politique
intérieure a un raisonnement à
l'extérieur et ce que nous disons dans
cet hémicycle a un impact de l'autre
côté de nos frontières monsieur le
ministre vous félicitiez lundi du succès
que vous considériez à votre politique
menée à partir de 2021 pour réduire de
30 vois de 50 % le nombre de visas
accordés dans certains pays qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment coopératifs
en matière de laisser passer
consulaire on partage pas nécessairement
le même constat mais néanmoins si vous
considérez que ça remplit son objectif
c'est très bien puisque cette politique
a pour l'instant été AB donné notre
commission des lois a souhaité
réintroduire enfin introduire cette
disposition dans ce dans ce projet de
loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui néanmoins il faut tenir
compte du fait que la situation
internationale a fortement évolué et
nous interrompons quelques instants le
débat dans l'émicycle car je suis avec
la Catrice les républicain Valérie Boyet
bonsoir bonsoir Valérie Boyet on vous a
entendu dans
l'émicycle un petit moment où l'émicle s
un peu plus échauffé autour notamment de
la question des mineurs
non
accompagné vous avez dit avec d'autres
sénateurs qu'aujourd'hui et bien les
départements de France la DF demande une
recentralisation de et bien de
l'accompagnement de ces mineurs non
accompagnés c'est aujourd'hui et bien
une une responsabilité qui incombe au
département c'est très lourd
financièrement et d'un point de vue de
de l'organisation qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de la réponse du gouvernement
que vous a opposé une fin de non
recevoir car ce n'a pas à être dans ce
texte a-t-il dit alors
plusieurs choses la première c'est que
effectivement le texte de présenté par
le ministre de l'intérieur par Gérald
Armana ressemble plus à un Gruère qu' un
fromage plus consistant et heureusement
que nous avons mis dans ce texte puisque
on l'a plus que doublé au niveau des
articles des éléments fondamentaux moi
ça me semble absolument abérrant que
dans ce texte on a parlé ni de
naturalisation ni des mariages ni des
mineurs non accompagnés et j'en oublie
pourquoi alors pour les minineurs non
acccompagnés c'est encore plus grave
parce que les mineurs non acccompagnés
bah c'est la gestion aussi des
collectivité territoriale mais c'est
aussi un détournement très clair de
plusieurs textes puisque ces personnes
arrivent fruduleusement sont Proix de
trafic d'êtres humains plusieurs
rapports ont montré dont le premier
rapport qu'il avait démontré c'est un
rapport un rapport sénatorial que plus
de 70 % n'étaient pas mineurs et
maintenant on sait qu'ils ne sont pas
non accompagnés puisqu'ils sont dans les
mains de pass
pour bon nombre d'entre eux dans la
délinquence ou la prostitution donc on a
à faaire à des affaires particulièrement
dramatiques et ensuite depuis la loi
taquet ils sont ils doivent être pris en
charge jusqu'à leur 21 ans et il faut
que les téléspectateurs sachent qu'il y
a des circulaires qui font en sorte
qu'ils soi naturalisé au plus vite à
leur majorité donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'ils arrivent
fruduleusement ils bénéficient d'une
prise en charge particulièrement lourde
et très très chè de la part de avec de
l'argent public puisque le coût d'un
mineor d'un MNA pris en charge alors
qu'il soit majeur ou mineur mais celui
qui est pris en charge par les
départements c'est 50000 € mais 50000 €
ça couvre pas tous ses frais hein il y
en a bien d'autres la santé l'éducation
et cetera tout ça n'est pas couvert et
ensuite ce sont des personnes et bien
qui qui qui deviennent françaises et qui
à ce titre là euh font dir une partie de
le famille alors
déjàà alors ça c'est le ça c'est le
c'est le c'est d'enfant normalement oui
alors pour les enfants il y a pas de
sujet sauf que quand même on pourrait se
poser la question de savoir que si notre
législation et si notre accueil n'était
pas aussi généreux peut-être que il
serait moins en proit au trafic d'êtres
humains vous savez qu'ils sont à plus de
95 % ce sont entre je crois 90 95 % des
garçons M ant on voit plus en plus de
filles arriver et des filles enceintes
parce que l'objectif pour les filles qui
arrivent et qui sont enceintes c'est
d'accoucher en France pour être certaine
de de de pouvoir y rester donc on a
quand même affaire à des situations qui
sont absolument dramatiques donc notre
système attire ce genre de personne
parce qu'ils savent parfaitement que
s'ils sont acceptés comme mineurs ou si
les filles accouchent en France et bien
c'est fini elles pourront plus partir
elles pourront bénéficier de notre
système mais en faisant ça ils se
mettent euh en danger et ils mettent en
danger aussi beaucoup de nos concitoyens
puisque vous savez quand même leur
surreprésentation à Paris dans la
délinquence et cetera j'y reviendrai
donc moi ce que j'ai demandé ce que j'ai
demandé ce que j'ai demandé c'est que
d'abord on peut s'étonner et
heureusement que le Sénat est là pour
évoquer ce sujet euh que on nit pas de
date pour la révision de la loi taquet
ni pour prendre ni pour répondre à la
détresse des départements parce que
beaucoup de de départements et notamment
je voudrais ça saluer le courage et la
vision de la présidente du département
des Bouches du rô Martine vassal qui
dénonçait récemment dans les colonnes du
Figaro la situation impossible dans
laquelle elle était puisque aujourd'hui
sous sa responsabilité il y a bien
évidemment l'enfant sans danger mais
compte tenu de l'engorgement de de l'azu
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance compte
tenu du coût de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et bien elle ne peut pas elle
ne peut plus prendre en charge ses
mineurs soi-disant soi-disant mineurs et
soit-disant
accompagné c'est RA pourquelle
exactement on demande que l'État pour
ceux qui ont entre 16 et 18 ans enfin
pour les plus âgés et d'ailleurs ceux
pour lesquels il y a un fort doute aussi
et bien l'état les prenne en charge on
demande que les tests soient
systématique parce que on peut plus se
permettre d'être dans cette situation à
la fois d'appel d'Er mais à la fois de
de de de de détournement de notre droit
et de notable aussi Valée BO oui enfin
on sait qu'ils le sont la plupart du
temps quand même ce sont des choses il a
un débat aussi sur la fiabilité des test
en tout cas il il est clair que les
derniers chiffres que nous avons c'est
plus de 70 % qui ne sont pas des mineurs
donc quand même à un moment donné c'est
comme les déboutés du droit d'asile ça
suffit de détourner n nos règles et nos
lois on a quand même un pays qui est
dans une grande tension avec ce Koo
migratoire et le détournement de nos
textes c'est c'est pas quand on est dans
un état de droit effectivement on a des
droits mais cet État de droit il n'est
pas là pour être spolié il n'est pas là
pour être pour que les textes soient
détournés donc ce qui est demandé c'est
que effectivement l'État prenne ses
responsabilités parce que si nous si
nous en sommes là aujourd'hui c'est
parce que l'État ne prend pas ses
responsabilités et ce défaut sur les
collectivités territorial et met
d'ailleurs en danger une partie de nos
compatriotes donc nous demandons que les
que l'État prennent en charge ces
mineurs et qu'on réfléchisse à un
véritable
statut du du du mineur étranger parce
qu'on ne peut plus continuer comme ça et
je me permets d'insister demain que vont
ne plus payer les département le RSA ou
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui en France
l'enfance en danger ne peut pas être
prise en charge il y a plus de place
pour l'enfant sans danger donc voilà où
nous conduit le fait que l'État ne
prenne pas ses responsabilités et
n'arrive pas à mettre fin au chaos
migratoire bien merci merci beaucoup
valéie Boyet d'avoir répondu à mes
questions car nous allons retourner dans
les micycle les discussions commment sur
l'article 14a qui est un article
important puisque il porte sur et bien
les les restrictions à la délivrance de
visa la conditionnalité de l'aide au
développement envers les États qui ne
sont peu coopératifs en matière
migratoire tout de suite on prend la
direction de l'émicycle vous le voyez
c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur Géral
d'manin qui s'exprime vous mettez et ça
il appartient effectivement au k d'oré
de le souligner sur qui vous mettez
votre empêchement ça ça peut être les
visas de manière générale pour ceux qui
viennent travailler les visas étudiants
les visas pour ceux qui VI en faet voir
un mariage une visite touristique une
visite professionnelle et puis il y a ce
qu'on appelle plutôt les élites qui
décident qu' soit patronal culturel
politique et lorsque vous mettez des
restrictions de visa sur ces personnes
ben en général celle qui décide il y a
en général de mon expérience depuis 3
ans et demi que je suis minintérieur du
répondant voilà alors non seulement ça a
marché mais en plus moi je peux
témoigner pour faire
d'innombrables placement une rencontre
internationale justement sur ces
questions extrêmement complexes et qui
ont intéressé tous les ministres avant
moi de l'intérieur et qui intéresseront
tous les ministres après moi de
l'intérieur c'est que
souvent le responsable qu' soit chef
d'État ou qui soit min l'intérieur ou m
d'aaires étrangères du pays vous dit
nous on aimerait bien pouvoir changer
visa contre LPC je caricature le propos
mais nous on applique la loi et dans
votre dans vos texte de loi on bien
regarder il n'y a rien qui permet en
effet de ne répondre à la loi et nous
respectons les lois souveraines d'un
pays mais là vous n'avez pas de
disposition qui qui qui l'évoque donc
cet argument étant dit je trouve que la
la la l'articulation imaginé dans le 14a
par la Commission et et et je crois de
bon à loi il n'est pas assez prescriptif
il n'empêche pas la diplomatie il
n'empêche pas les action du ministère de
l'Intérieur il n'empêche pas le qu d'oré
il ne vient pas contrarier notre
relation avec tel ou tel pays d'ailleurs
il n'est pas nominatif sur tel ou tel
pays mais il pose un cadre qui est
grosso modo un équilibre que la France
doit avoir entre les s passé consulaire
et les visas et je pense que c'est de
bonne à loi en tout cas ça mérite d'être
essayé et ça mérite d'être porté par
notre diplomatie par le ministère de
l'Intérieur donc non ça n'a pas déjà été
essayé ça n'a jamais été dans la loi
telle quelle et je pense que la façon
dont la commission l' écrit encouragera
sans doute nos diplomates nos
responsables du ministère de l'Intérieur
à porter la volonté du législateur qui
est le représentant du peuple français
qui veut que si on délivre des visas il
faut évidemment avoir des laissés passer
consulaires je dis autamment que pour
pour le groupe centriste et pour le
groupe LR il y a des amendements qui
sont déposés qui sont si je dire encore
plus dur qui sont la la la la
compensationfin la conditionnalité de
l'aide au développement avec les visas
et les S passés consulaires c'est c'est
c'est encore plus dur et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement ne donnera pas des avis
défavorables à cette position le
président de la République luême s'est
exprimé alors j'ai même ici sa citation
bien sûr le 24 septembre dernier il a
indiqué que nous devons tous les pays
européens mieux conditionner notre aide
au développement et une politique
responsable en matière migratoire les
Français ne comprennent pas évidemment
pourquoi on peut dépenser des centaines
de millions d'euros parfois plus pour
des pays qui ne délivrent pas de laisser
passer consulaire c'est effectivement
assez incompréhensible et sans lier
véritablement aide au développement
laisser passer il y a quand même un
minimum sans doute à respecter donc je
pense que par ailleurs on donnera des
avis d'accompagnement positif on va dire
ça comme ça de la part pour le groupe LR
et comme l'amendement de Monsieur
Marseille sur lafd donc je pense je
pense que dans cette dans ces conditions
il faut évidemment garder l'article 14a
compléter je l'espère tout à l'heure par
l'amendement de Monsieur Marseille
madame Nara
Souin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre alors certes ça
n'est pas dans la loi mais enfin c'était
c'est expérimenté puisque ma collèue ma
collègue henou l'a dit c'est déjà il y a
déjà des mesures de rétorsion parce que
c'est l'esprit hein de de ce qu'on veut
mettre maintenant gravé dans le marbre
de la loi qui a déjà été appliqué et et
et dans ces mesures de rétorsion qui
sont prises vis-à-vis de de plusieurs
pays du Maghreb dont l'Algérie et le
Maroc on voit déjà des conséquences
économique néfaste pour la France
puisque par
exemple sur le la ligne de TGV
rabatanger qui a été constru par la
France bizarrement maintenant il
semblerait que ce serait plutôt
l'Espagne qui tiendrait la côte pour qui
qui aurait qui pour obtenir le le la
ligne rabat Agadir donc on voit bien
qu'on dégrade nos relations y compris
économique avec ces pays euh on dégrade
on on rend la
France difficile d'accès à ceux qui
veulent venir légalement parce que pour
penir ceux qui viennent illégalement ça
n'a absolument aucun sens et très peu
d'efficacité nous ne nous ne remettons
pas en cause la nécessité de trouver les
moyens de d'obtenir plus de laisser
passer consulaire mais nous pensons que
c'est la mauvaise méthode et faire du
chantage également euh à l'aide publ ça
n'est pas non plus plus efficace que
souvent dans ces
pays-là c'est pas vraiment enfin les
populations qui sont impacté par le le
le la baisse de l'aide publique n'est
pas souvent les les première population
dont se préoccupent les gouvernements de
ces pays et au-delà du fait que c'est
nous nous l'estimons moralement
répréhensible donc c'est ça n'est ça n'a
aucune efficacité et donc c'est plutôt
ok d'orsé ça n'est n'est pas à la
commission des lois ce n'est pas dans un
texte qui dépend du ministère de
l'Intérieur que de de de graver dans le
marbre de la loi ce que doit être ce que
doivent être les mesures diplomatiques
et et le le le champ de négociation de
du ministère des Affaires étrangères
merci Monsieur
salmon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues nous sommes là typiquement
dans ce qu'on peut appeler la punition
collective puisque l'on fait porter la
responsabilité de choix gouvernementaux
à l'ensemble d'une population c'est une
stratégie de
laattention une stratégie qu'emploie en
permanence ce gouvernement qui nous a
mis à dos de plus en plus de pays dans
le monde et on se demande en ce moment
où est passée la diplomatie française
puisque on est toujours dans un espèce
d'acharnement et un acharnement qui
porte sur des populations je je me
demande jusqu'où on va aller dans ce
sens-là puisque ça ne peut pas porter
des fruits on nous parle d'aimer la
France de l'attractivité de la France et
bien en ce moment la France est en train
de s'opposer à de plus en plus de
pays merci Monsieur
Guay merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre là on a un
désaccord qui est
profond la stratégie de la tension entre
laisser passer et visa et est déjà
extrêmement
discutable extrêmement discutable
peut-être que ça porte ses fruits mais
franchement est-ce que c'est à notre
honneur d'aller à stratégie de la
tension alors que il y a besoin d'avoir
une stratégie diplomatique sur ces
questions pourquoi pénaliser des parents
qui veulent venir voir leur enfant un
étudiant une étudiante qui veut venir
ici
étudier des artistes burkinabd maliens
qui voulaient juste venir faire la
musique on fait de nous au mois de
septembre je le dis monsieur le ministre
la risée du monde la risée du monde
qu'andon a interdit à des artistes de
venir se produire en France donc ça
c'est déjà un débat mais y
ajouter maintenant un marchandage sur
l'aide publique au développement et la
possibilité de le restreindre non mais
attendez chers collègues là là les
Benton mais là vous dites sur un certain
nombre de domaines monsieur le ministre
je suis pas compétent par contre
maintenant vous pouvez aussi être
ministre des Affaires étrangères non
mais attendez d'ailleurs dans des pays
dont beaucoup bénéficient de l'aide au
développement dont nous avons une dette
dont nous avons une dette je le dis ici
et don de nombreuses grandes entreprises
françaises Contin continuent d'aller
exploiter là-bas des hommes et des
femmes mais aussi les matières premières
et donc nous nous allons dire s'il y a
pas de laisser passer on restreint non
sincèrement on peut pas laisser passer
ça à 23h30 c'est pas possible même à
minuit mais même tous les jours même le
matin vous avez raison non sincèrement
c'est c'est c'est pas acceptable on a un
débat sur la question du laisser passer
mais l'aide au public au développement
fait que il faut que nous Abol nous nous
supprimions cet
article monsieur le
ministre je vais pas lancer le débat sur
le fond parce que je crois qu'on a
changé les arguments je voudrais juste
dire à madame la sénatrice et à monsieur
le sénateur que j'ai toute compétence
pour en parler je vous signale que
ministère de l'Intérieur je suis
représenté au conseil de l'Agence
française du développement et madame la
sénatrice sachez que la politique des
visas elle est copartagée entre le
ministre des Affaires étrangère et le
ministre de l'Intérieur et que la
politique des consulat est copartagé
entre minaires étrangères minist
inérieur donc on soit pas d'accord c'est
une chose de dire qu'on avait de dire
qu'on n pas le droit d'en parler parce
que c'est pas ma compétence c'est tout à
fait faux le ministère de l'Intérieur à
copartage l'action
pardon non mais le ministère de
l'Intérieur a des compétences à les
compétences sur les visas et sur les
consulats voilà parce que c'est
des mais bien sûr que si je passe mon
temps en faire madame c'est 25 % de
montant de ministre de l'Intérieur voilà
donc voilà vous avez raison vous pouvez
désormais vous moquer mais au moins vous
avez dit quelques bêtises de ministre de
l'Intérieur non seulement et membre du
conseil de l'administration de la FD et
par ailleurs qu'opartage la politique
des visas et des consulats
madame Comou Mouret
oui je voudrais simplement reprendre la
parole pour mcrire en fau avec ce que je
je viens d'entendre vous voyez monsieur
le ministre qu' y a quand même un
consensus sur ces bans trois groupes
politiques se sont exprimés parce que
tout simplement voilà c'est notre
circonscription nous représentons les
Français établis hors de France
peut-être que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
interlocuteurs que vous mais ce que nous
observons quand même et ce que nous
entendons Mons minist vas-y vas-y
pardon oui
alors alors je continue oui ce que nous
observons sur le terrain quand même ce
sont des des statistiques euh qui nous
disent par exemple que l'Institut
français de Tanger voit une baisse de 30
% du nombre de ses étudiants qui sont
tous allés à l'Institut servantè que
aujourd'hui nous avons des marchés que
nous perdons au profit de certains de
nos concurrents européens et tout cela
est lié à la dégradation des relations
diplomatiques entre la France et
notamment le Maroc mais également la
Tunisie et et l'Algérie d'une autre
façon et ce qui est dommage c'est que
vous n'écoutiez pas finalement ceux qui
peuvent remonter les exemples de terrain
de ce qui se passe réellement et pas de
simplement ce que vous souhaiteriez
alors bien sûr que il faut des
négociations mais ces négociations
doivent se passer au niveau diplomatique
c'est ce que nous avons défendu et non
pas simplement dans un rapport de force
que nous allons perdre et que nous avons
déjà perdu donc ce n'est pas en
punissant aujourd'hui les quelques
encore francophones et francophiles de
ces pays qui n'ont aucun levier et aucun
pouvoir sur le le le le le pouvoir en
place que nous allons changer cette
politique donc voilà je je pense que ce
qui est proposé par la Commission va à
l'encontre de nos intérêts et notamment
de nos intérêt économique et je pense
que nous avons plaidé sur ces bans pour
que nous retirions cet amendement et
j'espère et bien que les collègues
auront été convaincus Monsieur
B je vous remercie je dois dire que
quand j'écoute un certain nombre
d'interventions à la gauche de
l'hémicycle je ne reconnais pas le texte
que notre commission des lois nous a
proposé bien entendu chacun d'entre nous
le sait nous ne pouvons pas réduire
notre relation diplomatique et nos
intérêts dans cette relation
diplomatique à la question de la
maîtrise des flux migratoires mais pour
autant nous ne pouvons pas non plus
ignorer dans cette relation diplomatique
cet enjeu essentiel pour la cohésion de
notre société j'ai vu beaucoup
d'amendements depuis le début de ce
débat venant de Van chers collègues
aucun ne
constitue un élément d'une politique de
maîtrise de la PR migratoire à chaque
fois c'est non non non et bien ce que
nous vous proposons ici c'est de dire
qu'on peut dans la politique d'aide au
développement prendre en compte
l'objectif de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière vous trouvez ça violent moi
je trouve que c'est la moindre des
choses si ces pays qui sont nos amis le
sont vraiment alors ils doivent savoir
en raison de cette amitié que nous avons
des choses qui sont très importantes
pour nous et nous aider à les mettre en
œuvre c'est pas une stratégie de
l'attention c'est une stratégie de
l'amitié d'abord l'amitié réciproque et
s'agissant des visas mais bien entendu
quand il est écrit le visa de long
séjour peut-être refusé au ressortissant
d'un État qui délivre un nombre vraiment
faible de laisser passer contulaire nous
envoyons un signal politique absolument
nécessaire mais nous ne rentrons pas
dans une démarche violente simplement
qu'il sacheent bien tous nos partenaires
que il y a des éléments essentiels à une
bonne relation avec la France et nous
Parlement français nous nous devons de
leur dire pour que la relation soit
saine et repose sur la
réciprocité madame Corbière
Namo je vous remercie monsieur le
Président chers collègues il
il il me faut quand même revenir pour
vous rappeler quelques petits éléments à
savoir que les Français les réunionnés
les Comoriens nous avons et les les les
Français d'outrem nous ne sommes pas
seulement amis avec ces pays nous avons
avec eux des liens de sang ce sont nos
frères et sœurs nous célébrons cette
année à la Réunion le
360e anniversaire du peuplement les
premiers qui sont venus sur l'île sont
des Malgaches donc nous sommes malgaches
arabes africain indiens chinois et nous
sommes français et nous sommes français
européens dans l'océan Indien cette loi
cet article qui vient conditionner
l'aide publique au
développement et bien il faut savoir que
la Réunion c'est un territoire de 2500
km² et que nous avons la grande île à
côté
avec 28 millions
d'habitants cette Madagascar
régulièrement frappé par la sécheresse
par la famine et vous venez nous dire
que nous allons conditionner l'aide au
développement l'aide au c-éveloppement
des pays de la zone à une politique
migratoire on veut freiner la migration
je vous rappelle qu'il y a eu une époque
dans l'histoire de la Réunion où on a
fait venir des travailleurs des migrants
pour occuper des métiers sous tension
cette période c'était la période de
langengagisme et et nous célébrons dans
de jours la mémoire de la fin de cette
période de travail honteux où des gens
sont venus des pays du du du de la zone
pour travailler à la place des esclaves
sur les plantations et dans les usines
donc je suis désolée mais depuis
quelques jours les débats qui se
tiennent et les propos qui se tiennent
dans cet hémicycle me renvoi
régulièrement à histoire douloureuse de
la Réunion et je je je je suis je suis
vraiment vraiment attristé de voir la
tenue de de ces propos je vous indique
que pour ma part ce n'est pas une France
pays des droits de l'homme que je vois
ici c'est une France qui se ratatine cor
merci
beaucoup madame
[Applaudissements]
Olivier voilà vous le voyz de parole se
multiplie autour de cet article 14a cet
article qui vise et bien à conditionner
l'aide publique au développement les
visas les laisser passer consulaires en
fonction et bien de la façon dont les
états coopère avec la France en matière
migratoire sur ce sujet on va justement
rejoindre Mathias Arz qui se trouve
toujours dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
Mathias qui suit pour nous tous les
débats dans cet hémicycle euh Mathias
comment se passe et bien l'examen de cet
article bah vous le voyez c'est un
article qui est largement débattu qui
fait vivement réagir sur la dans la dans
la gauche de de cette hémicycle c'est un
article qui a été ajouté par la
commission il n'existait pas dans le
texte initial du gouvernement cet
article 14a qui comme vous l'avez
expliqué th souhaite restreindre la
délivrance de visa et donc conditionner
également cette délivrance de visa et
bien également l'aide au au
développement envers les États qui sont
peu coopératifs en matière migratoire on
parle donc bien là des laisser passer
consulaires vous savez ces laisser
passer consulaires et bien qui
permettent lorsque la France expulse un
étranger en situation irrégulière et
bien de retourner dans son pays voilà
c'est la délivrance de visa dans l'autre
sens et bien c'est tout simplement comme
l' évoqué tout à l'heure Fabien Guay
bien la possibilité pour des artistes
maliens ou tchadiens qui sont des pays
qui finalement coopère peu avec la
France et bien de pouvoir venir en
France une mesure qui comme je vous le
disais n'était pas dans le texte
initiale mais qui a été tout de même
salué par le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald de
dararmanin
souvent le responsable qu'il soit chef
d'État ou qui soit mis à l'intérieur ou
m d'affaires étrangères du pays vous dit
nous on aimerait bien pouvoir é changer
visa contre LPC je caricature le propos
mais nous on applique la loi et dans
votre dans vos texte de loi n bien
regarder il n'y a rien qui permet en
effet de n répondre à la loi et nous
respectons les lois souveraines d'un
pays mais là vous n'avez pas de
disposition qui qui qui l'évoque donc
cet argument étant dit je trouve que la
la la l'articulation imaginée dans le
14a par la Commission et et et je crois
de bonne à loi il n'est pas assez
prescriptif et il n'empêche pas la
diplomatie il n'empêche pas les actions
du ministère de l'Intérieur il n'empêche
pas le qu d'orsé il ne vient pas
contrarier notre relation avec tel ou
tel pays d'ailleurs il n'est pas
nominatif sur tel ou tel pays mais il
pose un cadre qui est gr gr modo un
équilibre que la France doit avoir entre
les laisser passer consulaires et les
visas et je pense que c'est de bonne à
loi en tout cas ça mérite d'être essayé
et ça mérite d'être porté par notre
diplomatie par le ministère de
l'Intérieur voilà c'est un article qui a
donc créé du débat certains précisant
que ce n'était pas les les compétences
du ministère de l'Intérieur qu'on parle
là de compéten du ministère des Affaires
étrangères c'est ce qu'évoqué géralde
Darmanin en parlant de diplomatie le
ministre a toutefois précisé que si cet
article lui semblait intéressant il y a
une version qui a été réécrite par Hervé
Marseille le président de l'Union
centriste ici au Sénat proposant de
confier cette mission de contrôle à
l'Agence française du développement et
bien Géral d'an expliqué que cette
version lui paraissait peut-être plus
souhaitable merci merci beaucoup Mathias
et tandis que l'on voit effectivement
les débats qui se poursuivent autour de
cet article 14 et on va tout de suite
continuer à les suivre dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat dans les pays de départ or je
constate et vous m'avez d'ailleurs pour
une part donné raison monsieur le
ministre et je trouve qu'il est quand
même
dramatique que dans un projet de loi qui
traite des enjeux de l'imigration le
seul moment le seul moment où on parle
de l'aide au développement c'est pour
nous dire comment la
supprimer c'est quand même tragique
c'est quand même pathétique et qui peut
penser qu'on va tarrir les flux des
migrations si on n'agit pas sur les
conditions dans les pays de départ en
veillant améliorer les conditions de vie
des gens qui habitent sur place et qui
devrai pouvoir y vivre dignement je
pense quand même qu'on devrait se poser
quelques questions à la lumière de de
tout ça et des débats que nous avons
depuis quelques jours
maintenant monsieur le
moine
merci beaucoup monsieur le le président
bon en lisant l'article 14a tel qu'il
est rédigé en fait il y a deux sujets il
y a le sujet visa il y a le sujet de
développement et à travers cette
intervention je voulais peut-être
signaler qu'il y a je vois pas de vérité
absolue dans cette hmicycle ce soir sur
ces sujetsl et dire peut-être au ban de
la droite que sur le sujet des visas moi
j'ai en tête le courrier que le
président Cambon avait adressé au
Ministre Darmanin en septembre 2022 en
s'inquiétant
de des conséquences de visa contre LPC
et il disait je le cite c'est une
humiliation pour les Marocains donc
voilà ça c'est pour le sujet visa mais
je me tourne aussi vers les bancs de la
gauche sur le sujet de la
la rédaction du 14a dit que la
politique de développement solidaire
elle prend en compte prendre en compte
voilà l'objectif de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et j'ai lu
dans l'actualité internationale que pas
plus tard qu'hier par exemple le
président Macky Sall à l'issue du
conseil des ministres au Sénégal a
demandé à ce que une lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière résolue soit
conduite parce que c'est aussi de la
perte de talent et de compéten pour un
pays qui en a fondamentalement besoin et
comme tous ces pays qui cherchent qui
sont dans
l'émergence tout ça pour dire non mais
tout ça pour dire que l'article enfin
le l'article 14a dans son volet APD ne
mérite peut-être pas l'excès d'un
dignité qui est évoqué et qu'en revanche
sur la dimension visa ne pensons pas non
plus que c'est ça qui va régler le sujet
des LPC parce que il y a encore des
marches de progrès et donc et donc voilà
je crois qu'on doit aborder cet article
14 avec beaucoup d'humilité au regard
des enjeux qui sont vastes ça a été dit
enjeux diplomatique enjeu de
développement et que donc il faut se
comment dire faut éviter éviter de
prendre un certain nombre de raccourcis
que j'ai pu entendre ici et là sur ces
ban président
buffet monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je reviens pas sur les la
rédaction de l'article mais simplement
pour dire que dans un monde idéal
évidemment que vous avez raison nous
devons avoir de bonnes relations avec
l'ensemble des pays nous devons être
ouvert nous devons aider il y a pas de
difficulté mais ça c'est un monde idéal
dans la réalité de ce que l'on vit en
matière migratoire et ce depuis
longtemps on se rend compte très très
vite qu'il y a un certain nombre de pays
amis ou pas d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas
tout à fait dans cette logique et qui
utilisent aussi le fait de ne pas donner
de laisser passer consulaire comme des
moyens de pression comme des enfin
essentiellement comme des moyens de
pression d'ailleurs et que on se
retrouve ainsi dans difficulté par
exemple dans les centres de rétention
administrativ parce que au moment où on
veut raccompagner quelqu'un on n' pas
laissé passer consulaire dans le délai
c'est le hasard souvent mais pas
toujours où on l'obtient pas du tout et
puis petit à petit se construit comme ça
des comportements qui en réalité
traduisent une volonté de ne pas être
très coopératif pour voir même de ne pas
être du tout donc notre enjeu c'est
évidemment quand j'ai dis notre enjeu
collectif pour la France c'est pas d'
désagréable avec les autres pays du
monde c'est être agréable mais c'est
d'avoir aussi l'outil qui permette le
moment venu lorsque les choses se
tendent parce que il y a des rapports de
force qui sont existants qu'il faut
pouvoir les armer ces rapports de force
y compris dans les négociations et avoir
la possibilité de dire à un moment stop
vous n'aurez pas de laisser passer
consulaire parce que de visa pardon
parce que vous ne donnez pas vous
laisser passer consulaire et on sait que
ce n'est pas de bonne fois que vous nous
les donnez pas et c'est la possibilité
aussi denerok Dorset mais le ministre a
rappelé tout à l'heure la collaboration
de pouvoir s'interroger et mettre sur la
table la discussion de l'aide au
développement évidemment que nous
souhaitons tous que les choses se
passent bien malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas et pas toujours le cas et pas
en totalité le cas heureusement aussi
donc donnons à notre pays cet outil de
discussion donnons au ministrees en
place la capacité d'avoir cette
possibilité d'ouvrir cette discussion au
nom du Parlement français tout
simplement merci
madame de
lagonterie merci président j'aiécouté le
président buffet mais il y a quelque
chose qui qui m'intrigue c'est que en
fait la France n'a pas besoin de cet
article on est dans un domaine de
politique gouvernementale euh et que ce
soit l'aide au développement ou la
politique de visa il n'y a pas besoin
d'un article de loi pour mener telle ou
telle action que le ministère de
l'intérieur pour estimer nécessaire pour
obtenir les laisser passer consulire et
cetera et cetera d'ailleurs quand vous
l'avez fait en octobre 2021 de mémoire
il y a pas eu d'article de loi qui vous
y a ou autorisé ou demandé de le faire
vous l'avez fait parce que c'était votre
capacité de le faire ça a eu un succès
qu'on peut estimer relatif en terme de
qualité des relations diplomatiques avec
le Maroc en tout cas donc c'est c'est je
moi je ne comprends pas très bien alors
vous pourrez vous pourriez me répondre
oui mais d'ailleurs ce n'était pas dans
le texte initial
donc ce n'est pas une demande du
gouvernement c'est une initiative de la
commission des lois mais je trouve que
c'est un signe quand même extrêmement
raide qui est donné à un certain nombre
de pays je ne suis pas sûr que cela
puisse aider en quoi que ce soit puisque
de toute façon vous avez les moyens de
le faire et que j'ai cru comprendre que
lorsque vous l'avez mené en octobre 2021
un an après vous y avez renoncé en
revanche no relation avec le Maroc se
sont dégradé d'ailleurs nous l'avons vu
après le tremblement de terre et la
façon dont le roi du Maroc a estim ne
pas avoir besoin de notre aide à ce
moment-là
merci merci j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scoutin public
par sur ces amendements identiques par
la commission et par le groupe CRC
kanaki je rappelle que l'avis du
Gouvernement est défavorable l'avis de
la commission défavorable le scoutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande de
voter c'est bon
le Scotin est
clos votant 345 exprimé 344 pour 114
contre 230 les amendements ne sont pas
adoptés monsieur le ministre
juste une réflexion sémantique madame la
sénatrice de la Réunion évoqué tout à
l'heure les Français les les réunionnés
les comoriens j'imagine qu'elle voulait
dire les les Maorais puisque Mayotte est
une île française et que les Comores est
un État
étranger merci on va passer à
l'amendement
361 monsieur
Frassa merci monsieur le président
monsieur le
ministre je n'ai pas voulu venir puisque
le débat était largement commencé
sur l'aspect de l'aide publique au
développement l'amendement que je
présente avec l'ensemble des membres du
groupe LR a pour objet de préciser que
l'aide publique au développement donc
est conditionné aux objectifs de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière je
voudrais juste monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président préciser à mes
collègues des Français de étranger que
on doit pas visiter les mêmes pays pour
ma part j'en suis à mon 3è mandat j'ai
visité 189 pays certains de mes
collègues ont été élus il y a un mois et
je n'ai pas vraiment les mêmes
impressions et les mêmes retours que sur
les alertes qu'elles ont lancé
concernant les inquiétudes de nos
compatriotes pour ma part je suis
sénateur des Français et de l'étranger
et euh les Français peuvent circuler
jusqu'à pruve du contraire sans demander
des visas euh concernant l'aide publique
au développement je rappellerai
simplement que il s'agit de la
conditionné et non pas de l'arrêter
comme j'ai pu
l'entendre que on a demandé aussi l'avis
de la
ministre des Affaires étrangères je
rappellerai également que à une époque
qui remonte à peu près il y a un peu
moins de 20 ans du temps du regretté
président
Chirac il y a eu un problème avec le
Gabon et le Congo sur le paiement des
retraites des Français qui avaient
travaillé dans ces deux
pays à l'époque c'était madame Girardin
qui était ministre de la Coopération et
une certaine Catherine Colona était
conseillère auprès du président Chirac
et c'est elle qui avait avec Brigitte
Girardin mis en place le conditionnement
de l'aide publique au développement pour
le Gabon et le Congo si ces deux pays
refusaient de payer les retraites des
Français qui une fois après leur
carrière rentré en France ne touchit pas
les retraitees du Congo et du Gabon donc
je ne pense pas que la ministre actuel
trouve beaucoup à redire au
conditionnement de l'aide publique au
développement pour les pays qui ne
joueraient pas le jeu sur la délivrance
des laisser passer en matière
detf voilà merci quel est l'avis de la
commission l'avis de la commission est
est favorable monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues puisque vousvez compris
que cet amendement précise de façon
plutôt heureuse au sens de la commission
le précédent article qui a été cité qui
n'a pas été supprimé vous avez compris
aussi que la souplesse de rédaction de
l'amendement permet effectivement de
considérer cette modulation comme un
outil au service des intérêts de la
France en terme
d'immigration merci l'avis du
Gouvernement avis favorable de la
commission sagesse du gouvernement je
mets au voix cet amendement qui vote
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
amendement 513 madame Floren merci
monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement prévoit que la politique de
développement solidaire et de lutte
contre les inégalités mondiales tient
compte de l'objectif de lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière notamment
vis-à-vis des états délivrant un nombre
particulièrement faible de laisser
passer consulaire ou ne respectant pas
les stipulations d'un accord bilatéral
multilatéral de gestion des flux
migratoires si ce nouvel objectif est
légitime et en phase avec la politique
du gouvernement il convient de ne pas
retenir le critère de délivrance d'un
nombre particulièrement faible de
laisser passer consulaire dans la mesure
où le nombre de laissés passer
consulairire délivrés doit être évalué
non en terme absolus mais par rapport à
une demande qui est faite de plus la
coopération en matière de réadmission ne
se limite pas à la seule délivrance de
laisser passer consulaire et répond et
repose sur une évaluation qualitative
mise en œuvre par l'État et partager
avec les représentations diplomatiques
et consulaires enfin il est proposé
d'opérationnaliser cette objectif de
constitutionnalisation de l'aide au
développement en l'inscrivant dans les
missions de l'Agence française de
développement et sans se limiter aux
aides budgétaires distribué directement
aux États mais à l'ensemble de l'aide au
développement qu'elle attribue voilà
l'objet de notre amendement merci
monsieur le Président l'avis de la
commission au regarde l'objet de
l'amendement et de l'avis qui vient
d'être donné sur le précédent c'est
évidemment un avis favorable avis du
gouvernement sagesse avis favorable de
la commission sagesse du gouvernement je
mets l'amendement au voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté chers collègues
je mets au voix l'article
14a qui vote pour qui vote contre cet
article est
adopté je suis saisi de deux amendements
identiques le 227 qui présente monsieur
F merci monsieur le
président article cet amendement pardon
propose la suppression de l'amendement
de l'article 14 B qui nous apparaît être
une innovation d'ordre
bureaucratique issu de la commission
absolument pas nécessaire et donc nous
en proposons la suppression que prévoit
cet article 14b que lorsqu'un préfet
prend une mesure d'éloignement à
l'encontre d'un étranger il en informe
les organismes de sécurité sociale ainsi
que Pôle emploi soit mais évidemment
c'est les organismes ne peuvent pas
radier immédiatement l'intéressé puisque
l'étranger a le droit de contester l'qtf
auprès du juge administratif le texte
d'ailleurs du rapport de la commission
dit ensuite à l'expiration du délai de
recours contre la décision d'éloignement
ou le cas échéant lorsqu'une demande
d'annulation de cette mesure a été
définitivement rejetée par la
juridiction administrative ces
organismes pourront ainsi procéder à la
radiation de l'assurée donc pour
résoudre la difficulté du délai de
recours et des recours eux-mêmes
l'amendement pardon l'article 14 B donc
prévoit que les organismes de sécurité
sociale et Pôle emploi devront pour
chaque étranger concerné suivre les
délais de recours regarder si l'étranger
a intenté un recours et si c'est le cas
vérifier si la juridiction
administrative a ou non annulé la
décision d'éloignement est-ce que cela
relève des missions des organismes
sociaux de faire le suivi des procédures
contentieuses en droit des étrangers
est-ce que des moyens leur sont donnés
pour cela cela nous paraît tout à fait
obscur inutile peut-être dangereux
suivant ce qui est M mis en œuvre pour
assurer ce suivi et donc nous proposons
la suppression de cet article 14b
merci l'amendement 318 monsieur Baroche
merci monsieur le Président le le
mécanisme qui veut être mis en place par
l'article 14b a très bien été expliqué à
l'instant par vos collègu je je
rajouterai quelques éléments
déjà les personnes étrangères n'accèdent
pas aux prestations sociales dans les
mêmes conditions que les Français la loi
prévoit déjà des conditions plus
restrictives par ailleurs les
prestations celles-ci sont réservées aux
personnes installé durablement en France
et a une exception pré munie d'un titre
de séjour au contraire je le dis parce
que c'est souvent le cas et pas que dans
ce domaine on parle souvent des coûts on
parle jamais en fait des recettes qui
sont engendrées ou des coûts qui sont
évités donc je rajouterai quand même que
les personnes étrangères rest
durablement en France financent
aujourd'hui plus le système social
qu'elle n'en bénéficie en effet elles
arrivent souvent en France déjà formées
elles ont des parcours professionnels
plus courts et elles repartent très
souvent dans leur pays d'origine à l'âge
de la retraite même installé en France
en situation régulière les personnes
étrangères sont touchées par des
restrictions dans l'accès à plusieurs
prestations par exemple le RSA qui ne
peut être perçu qu'après avoir séjourné
au moins 5 ans avec un titre de séjour
autorisant à travailler de même
laallocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées dit minimum vieillesse requiert 10
années de résidence avec autorisation de
travail tout tout cela et nous
interrompons quelques instants cette
séance he vous suivez toujours le projet
de loi immigration avec notamment et
bien l'adoption de cet article 14a qui
vise à conditionner et bien les visas
les laisser passer consulaire l'aide
publique au développement en fonction et
bien de l'État des relations avec des
pays en matière de coopération sur la
politique migratoire je suis avec hen
Conway Mouret bonsoir sénatrice
socialiste des Français de l'étranger
vous avez été ministre des Français de
l'étranger qu'est-ce que vous inspire
l'adoption de cet article qui
précisons-le a été rajouté à
l'initiative de la Commission grande
déception une méconnaissance finalement
de ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
vous avez noté que les trois sénatrices
qui représente des groupes politiques
différents se sont toutes exprimés avec
des mots plus ou moins similaires pour
décrire ce qui se passe sur le terrain
c'est-à-dire que les mesures mises en
place pendant un an de restriction des
visas non seulement n'ont pas porté de
fruit en tout cas ceux qui étaient
escomptés mais ont commis des dégâts
collatéraux qui sont absolument
colossaux que l'on continue à payer avec
une baisse très significative du nombre
d'étudiants enfin de personnes qui
veulent apprendre le français avec la
perte de marché important notamment au
Maroc dommageable au niveau du
rayonnement culturel au niveau
économique aussi que vous dans tous les
secteurs d'activité je crois qu'il n a
pas un seul qui n'a pas été touché des
artistes qui n'ont pas pu venir en
France enfin la politique qui a été mise
en place était de refuser un visa sur
deux et donc il fallait trouver
n'importe quelle excuse pour rentrer
dans dans le quotat on a demandé à des
agents consulaires de faire ce travail-
là ils l'ont exécuté bien et donc
puisque on sait que de façon général à
peu près 14 % des visas sont refusés
quand on en refuse 50 % et bien il le
reste est tout à fait légitime pour
venir en France et ce sont des gens qui
ont fait leurs études en France qui
viennent chaque année en France pour des
raisons différentes et qu'on a humilié
en leur disant comme comme comme refus
comme raison de refus et et bien que
il présentaiit un risque migratoire
voilà donc ces gens aujourd'hui et bien
passent par l'Espagne ou par d'autres
pays moi j'ai des familles qui m'ont
écrit en me disant que et bien leurs
enfants sont dans les lycées français
qu'ils attendront la fin de leurs études
mais que ces enfants ne viendront
certainement pas faire leurs études
supérieurs en France parce que eux-mêmes
ne savent pas s'ils auront des visas
pourir les aider à s'installer pour leur
rendre visite pendant le temps de leurs
études et ainsi de suite donc on est est
en train d'envoyer des messages
incroyablement négatifs de fermeture de
nos frontières à ceux qui aiment notre
langue à ceux qui aiment notre culture à
ceux qui ont passé du temps avec nous et
que nous punissons et ce ne sont pas ces
gens-là qui vont frapper à la porte du
roi du Maroc pour lui dire que voilà il
faudrait que la relation entre le Maroc
et la France par exemple s'améliore donc
on a tout faux on punit les mauvaises
personnes avec les mauvais moyens et
tout ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est
simplement entrer est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire tout de même pour que et bien les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français puissent davantage aboutir
puisque effectivement le problème c'est
qu'il faut que l'étranger en situation
irrégulière puisse rentrer dans son pays
qui n'est pas toujours le casû bien sûr
et et bien sûr nous soutenons cela et
moi j'ai participé avec une casquette de
ministre délégué des Affaires étrangères
il y a une dizaine d'années où pendant
des mois entiers nous négocions avec nos
homologues c'était pas souvent facile
mais nous ne sommes jamais rentrés dans
un rapport de force de punition ou de
mesure de rétorsion parce qu'on arrivait
pas à nos fins nous arrivions à un
compromis aujourd'hui l'état des
relations diplomatiques entre la France
et ces pays est tel qu'il faut rentrer
dans un rapport de force et non pas de
négociation et c'est ce qu'on attend de
la diplomatie donc moi j'aimerais qu'on
en revienne simplement à pouvoir
discuter autour d'une table trouver une
solution et ne pas punir les mauvaises
personnes bien merci beaucoupl mour le
message
est passé alors que et bien les débats
se poursuivent toujours he sur ce projet
de loi immigration tout de suite on
reprend donc la direction de l'hémicycle
je mets au voix l'article
14b qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
adopté je suis saisi de deux trois
amendements identique le
193 monsieur Chillou
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
cette amendement propose tout simplement
de supprimer l'article 14 C qui
finalement vient démontrer la la
surenchère auquelle nous assistons
depuis le début de cette semaine avec la
multiplication d'un S de
dispositions qui vise tout simplement à
réduire et à multiplier des délais qui
parfois n'ont pas de non logique y
compris sur la base de fondement
d'arguments qui nous semble absolument
pas rationnel puisqu'il s'agit là en
l'occurrence de porter la durée maximale
mesure d'assignation dans l'hypothèse
d'unqtf jusqu'à 135 jours c'estàd de
rajouter 45 jours au 90 jours qui
existent déjà notamment parce que le
pays d'origine n'a pas délivré le laissé
passer consulaire et il nous apparaît
que y compris rajouter ces 45 jours
montre que très clairement la
perspective de l'éloignement et donc que
mettre fin à cette mesure de contrainte
apparaît assez aléatoire et donc il nous
semble là aussi
euh
absolument inutile de rajouter encore
ces délais contenu des perspectives très
faibles de mise en œuvre et donc nous
proposons tout bonnement d'en rester au
droit en vigueur et de supprimer cet
article qui par ailleurs nous semble peu
compatible avec la Constitution merci le
321 monsieur
bénaroche voilà encore le mécanisme de
cet article a très bien été expliqué à
l'instant
euh la la seule question que je
poserai aujourd'hui au ministres et à la
commission des lois
c'est qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser que
en dehors de la valeur symbolique qui
consiste à dire on va plus contrôler on
va plus contraindre parce que bon
l'assiliation en résidence est une
contrain aussi est une privation de
liberté également il faut pas croire que
c'est juste une mesure qui serait moins
disante et plus et plus souple
euh que le fait d'être en CR et de dire
ben finalement faut bien asser résidence
4 en CR on a bien vu que c'était pas
pour les mêmes personnes le ministre a
très bien expliqué tout à l'heure il a
très bien expliquer qui étaient les gens
qu'il visaient pour aller dans des cras
et donc les autres seront assignis à
résidence pour autant c'est une
privation de liberté donc la question
que je pose en fait c'est aujourd'hui
quels sont les éléments qui nous font
dire ou qui vous font penser ou qui en
dehors des des effets bien entendu
d'annonce d'affichage ou de
symbole que le fait d'augmenter la durée
de l'assiliation en résidence va avoir
des effet positifs sur ce que vous visez
c'est-à-dire le fait d'expulser ou
d'arriver effectivement à faire exécuter
plus
deqtf merci Monsieur brossa pour le 373
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 14 C prévoit d'étendre la
durée maximale d'assignation à résidence
d'un étranger faisant dans l'objet d'une
qtf et dont l'éloignement semble se
profiler à deux renouvellements de de 45
jours au lieu d'un seul soit jusqu'à 135
jours tout d'abord cela n'accélérera en
rien la procédure d'expulsion au
contraire elle sera de fait prolongée et
avec elle sera prolongé une importante
restriction de liberté par ailleurs son
délai qui pourra donc atteindre 4 mois
et demi se rapprochera grandement de
celui de l'assignation à résidence à
long délai qui lui est de 6 mois or
cette dernière concerne les personnes
dont l'éloignement ne se profile pas et
il y a donc là un certain paradoxe
d'autre part l'argument principal
utilisé par les défenseurs de cette
mesure consiste à dire que ce temps
supplémentaire serait notamment de
nature à favoriser l'obtention d'un
laisser passer consulaire or il demeure
tout de même assez peu probable que les
relations diplomatiques avec le pays en
question évolue sur une telle période si
en 90 jours l'éloignement n'a pas pu
être misise en œuvre c'est donc qu'il ne
se profilit pas et nous ne voyons pas en
quoi un délai supplémentaire de 45 jours
y changerait quoi que ce soit pour
toutes ces raisons nous demandons la
suppression de cet
article va consulter la
commission nos avis sont défavorables
vous dire que nous sommes totalement
convaincus de l'efficacité pratique de
la mesure serait assez
excessif nous
avons donner un avis favorable pour une
autre raison c'est que bien entendu il
n'y a rien discrétionnaire dans tout
cela puisque le renouvellement est
décidé par le juge je pense que c'est
lui qui appréciera individuellement la
situation voilà le vrai motif de notre
avis des favorable avis du gouvernement
deux avis défavorables je mets au voix
l'amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement
637 monsieur Bonnec peut-être pas même
vote monsieur le Président puisque c'est
un amendement que nous présentons au nom
de la commission des des lois il vise à
apporter une réponse à une un sujet qui
vous a probement souvent été évoqué par
vos concitoyens ou par nos concitoyens
dans le casre des assignations résidence
vous le savez tous les frais de ces
assignations à résidence
et en particulier l'nuité hôtelière sont
à la charge de l'État nous proposons que
ce principe soit modifié et que les
frais d'assignation résidence soient mis
à la charge de l'étranger concerné alors
je précise immédiatement qu'il s'agit de
celui qui en a les ressources s'il n'en
a pas les ressources bien entendu comme
actuellement l'état assurera la
couverture des frais d'assignation en
résidence ce n'est pas une grande mesure
mais c'est quelque chose qu'à mon avis
chacun de nos concitoyens peut assz
assez aisément
comprendre monsieur le
ministre le Gouvernement est favorable
évidemment à cette mesure monsieur le
rapporteur il s'agit bien de personnes
qui sont qui troublent l'ordre public
qui doit euh qui doivent peut-être
pendant leur assignation à résidence
travailler cela peut être possible et
donc ils peuvent aussi avoir des
rémunérations indépendamment du capital
qu' peut avoir personnellement comme l'a
très bien dit monsieur le rapporteur
s'il s'agit de gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens bien évidemment il s'agit pas de
leur faire payer mais il y a bien de
solidarité nationale c'est effectivement
je crois une proposition de bon
sens madame de La
Gonterie merci monsieur le Président je
je je lis effectivement alors la
précision du ministre est importante
concernant les les moyens mais je
voulais juste savoir si vous considériez
que cela devait s'appliquer également au
français je demande si cette mesure
devrait s'appliquer également au
français assigné à résidence parce que
nous en connaissons quelques-uns et
compris certains
célèbres je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement
avec un avis favorable du
Gouvernement bien sûr l'amendement de la
commission qui vote pour
qui vote
contre l'amendement est adopté l'article
est ainsi
rédigé pass c'est à deux amendements
discussion commune le 557 monsieur
ravier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues cet amendement a pour ambition
de supprimer les aides financières au
retour et la réinsertion prévue par le
cza comme c'est déjà le cas à Mayotte en
quoi consistent ces aides au retour et
et à la réinsertion des étrangers dans
leur pays d'origine la liste est longue
une aide administrative pour la
préparation du voyage une prise en
charge des frais du voyage une
allocation de 650 € pour la personne
expulsée et le même montant pour son
conjoint au sa conjointe et ses enfants
une allocation forfaitaire
complémentaire de 150 € si vous avez un
passeport en cours de validité une
allocation destinée à faciliter la
réinsertion dans le pays de retour
montant allant de 400 € pour une
personne désolé à 300 € pour un enfant
mineur à charge et à 800 € pour un
couple à ce s'ajoute éventuellement une
aide technique et un suivi de projet
dans le pays de départ l'OFI peut
également décider d'accorder une
majoration de cette aide financière le
montant de cette majoration peut
atteindre 1200 € n'en jetez plus la
coupe est pleine elle déborde même sur
le plan économique avec des prélèvements
obligatoires qui atteinne 45 % du PIB
l'État français doit stopper la
redistribution injustifiée selon l'OCDE
les aides sociales versées par la France
aux étrangers représentaient déjà entre
15 et 20 milliards d'euros par an Bruno
Le Maire nous a dit que nous étions à
l'euro prês les Français oui mais l'État
avec notre argent manifestement toujours
pas l'état doit cesser de faire preuve
de générosité envers le monde entier au
point d'apparaître comme un guichet
social pour le Tiers Monde et d'inciter
à
l'immigration merci
amendement
640 qui
présente
monsieur le rapporteur ouiontier il
s'agit d'un
amendement qui relativise immédiatement
la portée de ce que l'on vient
d'entendre puisque il précise que l'aide
au retour ne peut-être attribué qu'une
seule fois ce qui me permet également de
vous donner d'ors et déjà l'avis
sur l'amendement de Monsieur ravier
d'une part l'aide au retour n'est pas
une aide sociale deuxièmement je pense
que vous devriez être plutôt favorable à
une mesure qui vise justement à
permettre à un certain nombre
d'étrangers de revenir dans leur pays et
que si vous estimez que cette mesure
pourrait faire l'objet d'un abus le
l'amendement que nous présentons disons
une seule fois répond à votre
préoccupation en tout cas il est bien
entendu que notre amendement 640 n'était
pas destiné à amender le 557 les deux
choses sont indépendantes avis
défavorable bien sûr sur le
premier monsieur le
ministre défavorable à Monsieur ravier
sagesse sur celui du
rapporteur on met au voix l'amendement
557 défavorable double double avis
défavorable qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté le 640 avec deux
avis favorables qui vote pour qui vote
contre
adopté amendement
357 madame ashliman
oui monsieur le Président l'amendement
de notre collègue Henri Leroi est très
largement cossigné vise à faire du
placement en rétention des étr
dont l'éloignement est une perspective
raisonnable la règle et de leur
assignation à résidence l'acception sans
diminuer les garanties au titre des
libertés individuelles entourant les
procédures de placement et de maintien
en rétention il est attendu de cette
mesure de permettre de rendre plus
efficace l'exécution des décisions
d'éloignement
merci merci quel est l'avis de la
commission nous venons de passer la
barre des minuits comprend que euh il
puisse y avoir un peu plus d'audace dans
l'expression mais l'amendement présenté
qui vise à faire du placement rétention
le principe en matière d'éloignement me
paraît quand même particulièrement
audacieux pour ne pas dire périlleux et
il vousz bien sûr il sera bien entendu
demander un retrait ou un avis
défavorable et si je revenais un esprit
un peu pratique euh nous avons quand
même entendu pendant une large partie de
la soirée de ministre de l'Intérieur
nous dire laissez-moi concentrer sur mes
cas les plus sérieux pour la société
française les places en cras j'avoue que
si on faisait de la rétention un
principe l'exercice deviendrait vraiment
compliqué pour lui avis bien sûr
défavorable du gouvernement
oui je veux dire madame la sénatrice que
évidemment c'est un avis défavorable
d'abord parce que c'est évidment
contraire à la directive retour
deuxièmement c'est contraire à notre
politique en fait de centre de rétention
et puis imaginons que je dise oui madame
la sénatrice et que vous le
votiez j'attends les propositions de
toutes les communes de France pour
installer des centres de rétention
administratif j'ai écrit à beaucoup de
monde je constate d'ailleurs je le dis
ici que aucune ville rassemblement
national n'a accepté de proposer des
terrains pour un centre de rétention
administratif voà je remercie beaucoup
de Mair qui soit de droite et de gauche
qui me ont évidemment proposé des
terrains mais aucun maire du
rassemblement national donc je conclu
que finalement C de rétention c'est
comme les prisons il en faut beaucoup
mais pas chez soi
merci Madame c'était bien tenté mais
nous le retirons ok l'amendement est
retiré donc je vais passer à de
amendements en discussion
commune
639 sagitè d'une disposition que le sén
adopté 2018 elle concerne les
dublinés mais et effectivement on
prévoit une extension des cas de
placement rédention mais de manière tout
à fait ciblée il s'agit des dubinés qui
refusent de donner leur empreinte ou qui
altère volontairement les documents les
concernants donc nous sommes sur des
situations très spécifique pour lequel
il nous apparaît qu'il est normal que
l'État prenne des garanties pour
s'assurer euh de pouvoir permettre au
dublinés de retourner dans le pays euh
de première accueil merci le
115 monsieur auchochard
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues par cet
abonnement nous souhaitons inscrire
comme critère caractérisant un risque de
fuite le refus d'un étranger de se
soumettre au relevé de ses empreintes
digitales ou encore s'il alterre
volontairement ces dernières pour
empêcher leur enregistrement pour rappel
le risque de fuite correspond à la
volonté de l'étranger expulsé de se
soustraire intentionnellement à la
mesure d'éloignement qui lui est notifié
il est clair qu'un refus de se soumettre
au relev ses empreunte constitue
indéiablement un comportement suspect
indiquant un potentiel risque de fuite
de l'étranger par cet amendement nous
appelons ainsi à considérer l'étranger
qui devant être expulsé refuse de se
soumettre au relever de ses empreintes
comme souhaitant potentiellement fuir la
mesure qu'il subit et impose son
placement provisoire enens de détentions
administrative euh 116 en même
temps
euh amendement dans la même lignée
effectivement n nous souhaitons par cet
amendement rétablir la législation
actuelle telle qu'elle existait avant
avant 2018 notamment le fait que pour un
étranger dissimuler des informations sur
son parcours et ses antécédents
familiauxx ou migratoires constituerait
des éléments suspects sur les intentions
de l'étranger et sa volonté d'intégrer
et de respecter les règles et la culture
de notre pays ainsi une telle
dissimulation participe logiquement on
un risque de fuite de l'étranger en cas
de notification une décision d'expulsion
nous demandons ainsi que soit rajouté à
l'article 751-10 du czda un renforcement
des conditions pour qualifier un risque
de fuite d' migrant ne soant pas
transparent sur son parcours auprès
autorités françaises devant lesquelles
il demande de jouir du droit d'asile sur
les amendements le rapporteur la
Commission a la prétention de considérer
que son amendement est plus complet et
je vous demanderai donc en adoptant
l'amendement que nous vous avons
présenté d'en tier ceci entraentraînera
comme conséquence de faire tomber les
deux autres amendements
ce qui m'évite d'avoir vous donné une
appréciation sur ces deux
amendements les amendements monsieur le
ministre votre avis
oui rapidement un avis défavorable aux
trois amendements et Monsieur rapporteur
je peux comprendre votre volonté en soit
elle dérange évidemment pas le
gouvernement mais si je comprends vous
voulez rajouter pour ceux qui refuserit
donner sur leur identité le fait qu'on
applique les Duin mais si on connait pas
leur identité ça pas être très simple
d'appliquer le fait qu'il soit dubliné
puisqu'on saura pas qu' le son donc il
me semble que cet amendement je
comprends le principe mériterait d'être
retravaillé si vous permettez lorsqu'on
fera la navette a l'assemé nationale
mais je préférais qu'il ne soit pas
adopté je vais consulter sur les trois
amendements le 639 je vais demander
votre avis qui vote
pour qui vote
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté les
deux autres
tombes amandement
638 c'est un renforcement des sanctions
pénalesorable avis favorable du
Gouvernement avis favorable de la
commission qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
adopté amendement
486 merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement notre collègue George patian
propose d'allonger de 4 à 8h la durée
maximale de rétention au fin de
vérification d'identité applicable en
Guyane déjà applicable à Mayotte cette
mesure derogatoire est justifié par les
contraintes géographiques spécifiques à
la Guyane en effet dans ce territoire
couvert à 97 % par la forêt amazonienne
les vérifications d'identité nécessitent
souvent que la personne soit conduite
dans un local de police or le simple
fait de rejoindre le lieu de rétention
peut prendre plusieurs heures et donc
dépasser le délai de
4h merci quel est l'avis de la
commission favorable l'explication est
particulièrement claire monsieur le
ministre je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre l'amendement est
adopté mes chers collègues je vais lever
la séance nous avons examiné 150 2
amendements au cours de la journée il en
reste 124 à examiner sur ce texte
prochaine séance vendredi 10 novembre à
9h30 pour la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi pour contrôler l'immigration
améliorer l'intégration chers collègues
la séance est
levée et voilà les débats sur le projet
de loi immigration sont donc terminés
pour aujourd'hui il y a encore pas mal
de travail hein pour demain 125
amendements à débattre à partir de 9h30
alors aujourd'hui certain nombre de
dispositions importantes ont été
adoptées notamment les articles 9 et 10
qui facilit la levée de protection
contre les mesures d'expulsion les
peines d'interdiction du territoire
français les octtf pour et bien les
étrangers qui représente un trouble à
l'ordre public qui sont notamment des
articles qui sont présentés comme des
réponses après l'attentat d'aras pour
lequel il a été très difficile
d'expulser une personne arrivée avant 13
ans en France autre point important et à
noter l'article 13 qui crée notamment un
contrat d'engagement au respect du
principe de la République auquel devra
souscrire un étranger qui obtient ainsi
un titre de séjour et enfin noter et
bien cet article 14a qui conditionne la
délivrance de visa de laisser passer
consulaire l'aide au développement à la
coopération en matière migratoire de
pays d'origine des étrangers tout de
suite on va rejoindre également à
Mathias Arz qui se trouve toujours dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat Mathias alors que
et bien ça commence à partir de
l'hémicycle pour nous dire un petit peu
ce qui nous attend sur ce texte oui vous
avez raison t l'hémicycle qui est en
train de se vider bien rapidement alors
les sénateurs ouvriront demain vous
l'avez dit le titre 3 de ce projet de
loi immigraç le titre 3 qui vise à
sanctionner l'exploitation des étrangers
et mieux contrôler les fr frontière dans
ce titre on retrouve notamment des
articles pour criminaliser la
facilitation en bande organisée de
l'entrée et du séjour d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière sur le territoire
français un article pour durcir les
sanctions contre l'habitat indigne ou
encore la possibilité et bien de
permettre l'inspection visuelle des
véhicules particuliers par les officiers
de police judiciaire en zone frontalière
ça c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
soulignait l'absurdité pour instant de
l'impossibilité pour les officiers de
police judiciaire de le faire par
exemple dans la région de Menton des
travaux qui se poursuivront en longueur
demain à partir de 9h30 ici dans cet
hémicycle et qui devront s'accélérer
hein d'une certaine manière puisque
comme vient de le vient de le rappeler
le président de séance il reste au total
encore trois titres à à ouvrir à
examiner ici plus de 130 amendements et
on le sait Tam et bien ce texte de loi
ce projet de loi immigration et bien il
attend un vote solennel pour mardi
prochain ici dans l'hémicycle merci
merci beaucoup Mathias de m'avoir
accompagné tout au long de cette soirée
et de cet après-midi pour faire vivre
les débats autour du projet de loi
immigration merci beaucoup à toutes les
équipes techniques qui vont se coucher
tard pour vous faire vivre ce texte
merci également à Cécile EV merci à
Mathilde nutarelli merci à Lucile gadler
merci à Cécile Siou merci à Romain
qui est en train de mettre et bien les
derniers points à ces articles que vous
pouvez lire sur
publicsenat.fr et qui vous explique et
bien toute la séance sur ce projet de
loi immigration et merci beaucoup à Pine
Tarna qui a supervisé encore une fois
toute cette soirée et c'est donc fini
pour aujourd'hui vous pourrez suivre
encore et bien condenser des meilleurs
moments de la séance demain après-midi
consacré au projet de loi immigration
avant Mathias le dis et bien le vote
solennel mardi prochain très bonne nuit
sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat